all right you're good to
go good morning everyone I'll call this
meeting of the house Judiciary Committee
to
order as chair of the house Judiciary
Committee I find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the covid-19 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order
2020-4 this public body is authorized to
meet
electronically this is a public hearing
of bills referred to the Judiciary
Committee the executive session on
pending legislation may be
held but not expected today please note
that there is no physical location for
members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
Zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court
website the notice for this meeting
complies with house rules and RSA 91
hyphen a anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should call
271-3600 that's
271-3600 or email HCS
l.st do. us that's HCS
l.st do. Us in the event the public is
unable to access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned and
rescheduled uh
we are we have a staff member who is
assisting us today and I'd like to
introduce that staff member her name is
Jennifer 4 she is the committee
researcher please note that all votes
that will be taken today during this
meeting will be by roll
call we're going to start the meeting by
taking roll call attendance as each
member states their presence they should
also State whether there's anyone in the
room with them during this meeting which
is required under the right to no
law and Mr clerk would you like to take
attendance V to so Mr chairman are you
here I am here I am in the Legislative
Office Building in committee room
20628 with fellow committee members
representative clim I am here and I'm
I'm in that same room in the L
representative Sylvia home alone in
Belmont
the clerk is here in room
208 Joe Alexander represent morning I am
here in Goffstown my roommates are in
and out of the
rice representative silver I'm here in
Guilford in my home office uh by myself
except for my
dog representative green I'm here my
home in Hudson with my
wife representative
Kelly I'm here in Temple alone with the
dog representative Tosh is not here
representative Tosh you are not here
right we talk representative T
here good morning I'm here at my home in
Belmont uh in my office alone there are
three children in the house
though representative
Smith um I'm here alone in
Durham
representative I'm here uh in West Milan
my son is in and out otherwise I'm alone
representative
Oregon I'm I'm here in Durham by
myself representative
deeno good morning I'm here at my home
office in New Market and my husband is
in and out of the house thank you
representative
Chase representative
Chase representative Kenny good morning
I'm here I'm in Durham in my apartment
I'm alone in my room but my roommates
are within the apartment thank
Langley representative
lley um Mr clerk she's in the attendees
again
today representative
McBeth yes um representative McBeth is
in her alone in her Virtual Office and
Portsmouth and um clerk I'll just give
you the report that I gotten a text from
uh representative Chase saying she's
having difficulty signing
on her internet's not working or
thank you thank you representative Paige
good morning I'm in exitor in my home
office with three children in the house
thank
you representative
Simpson good morning I'm here in my
house in exiter alone for the moment but
my spouse and two kids may be in and out
later in the
day great okay so we just missing
representative rice and three no
representative representative Langley is
is on the
line represent Langley uh
yes Mr chair it's representative Langley
I'm here at home in Manchester with my
Lang okay to I just uh before we begin
just want to tell the committee that um
last night after I got home after I did
the snowblowing I checked my emails
found I had
700 plus emails last night I'm sure
you've all have a number of emails as
well and as I went through them I found
that we have been assigned Friday the
19th as a hearing
day uh it's not ideal uh since it is a
Friday uh but uh we do need to have the
hearings and I know it'll be
inconvenient for some I did schedule
bills for that day and sent out an email
to everyone I think a little after
midnight last night so you should have
day not crazy about being on a Friday
but I think we do have a ton of bills
and we do need to get them
done we begin today uh with
hearings our first two hearings uh will
the first two bills we hear today will
be he heard
contemporaneously we're going to hear
House Bill 434 prohibiting the use of
public funds for abortions and House
Bill 596 FN prohibiting Public Funding
of abortions and establishing the New
Hampshire foster care and adoption
initiative
fund there are a number of people who
have signed up on these bills with
regard to 4 34 there are 21 people and
with regard to 596 there are 13 people
so
we'll adopt the same rule that we did
yesterday I'll allow the sponsors to
introduce their bill bills and then
we'll limit uh testimony to three
minutes uh
each
[Music]
and and what I will do in advance is
call names uh maybe five or so names of
people so that they can prepare uh at
the
time the uh just also for your
information
purposes those are the number of people
who indicated that they would
testify but on House Bill
434 there were 451 people who registered
their support for the bill and 800 185
who registered their
opposition and with regard to House Bill
596 there were 97 who registered their
support and
opposition so we'll uh begin our hearing
today on house go
434 the primary sponsor being
representative
shahim Shen excuse me and is
representative Sheen available I see yes
I am um can you hear me you can okay you
may proceed thank you Mr chair um good
morning I'm Vanessa Sheen and I
represent Milford Hillsboro District
23 this bill that I'm introducing does
one thing only it prohibits direct
funding of abortions or the termination
of a pregnancy specifically it bars
public funds from being spent on
abortions
public schools from performing abortions
or providing medication that would
terminate a pregnancy or public
employees from performing abortions
within the scope of their employment
this bill has one exception however and
that's when the mother's life is
endangered this bill also prohibits
publicly uh funded referrals made to
facilitate an
abortion this bill is an administrative
measure only so therefore it has no
penalties and this bill is in no sense
about permitting or prohibiting
abortion this bill would not prohibit
Planned Parenthood or other
organizations that perform abortions
from receiving Public Funding for other
purposes and there's no argument to be
made that this bill would have some
detrimental impact on Women's Health
Care there's no reason not to pass this
bill unless the general court insists
that abortions be directly financed by
taxpayers this is also Common Sense
housekeeping measure the general Court's
budget prohibited State funding of
abortions in the fiscal Years 2012
through 2013 2018 through 2019 and 2020
through 2021 so this legislation would
make it unnecessary to continue
rehearsing that same provision and
please note I have submitted a proposed
amendment to this bill which says that
it would not apply to abortions received
by Medicaid recipients under the state's
Medicaid plan this bill is a
housekeeping State matter and it is not
intended as a challenge to the federal
Medicaid act I become aware that this
bill could be challenged if this is not
made clear and I believe the amendment
that I've proposed will resolve that and
testimony and the prime sponsor of House
Bill 596 was representative plet and is
representative plet available to testify
this
morning
I do not see him on the attendee
list I am here
okay yes I'm I'm a member of the
audience and I had to unmute um thank
you I was was not aware of House Bill
434 when I put House Bill 596 fnn
they're both at this for the same
general purpose both laudable uh mine
goes a little further and it not only
Pro prohibits Public Funding of
abortions for convenience abortions only
not any other kind of abortion but also
creates a New Hampshire foster care and
adoption initiative fund um I think both
bills are laudable um the concern I I
was considering uh suggesting itl in
mind but as I thought more about it uh
the concern I have with HB 434 is a
enforcement mechanism is a concern and
there may be some concern about
constitutionality because of an Alaska
case and so I'm going to let this play
out and let the let the Judiciary
Committee come to a conclusion uh which
should Prevail thank
you thank thank you for your testimony
are there any questions for
representative
CL yes uh representative
Alexander um thank you Mr chair and
thank you to my fellow um gtown rep for
taking my question um I'm seeing in um
HB 434 I don't see necessarily a penalty
written in um is there one in
596 um for for breaking this this
specific law yes the uh they can be
fined for doing that and that's that's
what establishes the uh uh that's what
establishes the uh uh New Hampshire
Foster car adoption initiative fund
fines and um followup Mr chair yes um
would would the sponsor of HB 434 be uh
fine um
no okay thank
you representative Morgan um yes good
well you you're sounding good
representative PL my question is um
there's several um sections there which
deal with secular humanis gives what
um gives a definition of what secular
humanism is with no people who actually
consider secular humans would not agree
with any of it so what's the uh what how
why is that part of the bill in the bill
I'm not even sure why it's why it's
necessary doesn't seem to complicate
things so um especially in um and it
also probably runs a foul of both
federal and state constitutions but
anyway so why why is that necessary to
your bill say stuff about secular
humanists okay that language comes from
the Supreme Court uh which defines
secular humanism that way and it's in
there so that uh people who were
espousing uh concerns about uh uh Public
Funding of convenience abortions I put
in second place uh because uh you know
keep your keep your rosaries off my
ovaries uh secular humanism is very much
a religion as well so it's a battle of
uh whose View should Prevail not not uh
anybody with a religious bent is second
class because secular human is is also a
religion followup yes you may follow up
um what would the do you have a site for
the is this the state or the US Supreme
Court do you have a citation for that I
I've uh I'm totally unaware of that case
even though I I I my ignorance I'll
defer to some of the following speakers
on this bill to answer that
okay okay all right fine thanks a lot Mr
chair thank you thanks a lot represent
today to call on the following five
people um Christopher Hager Sarah AER
Christine
Arno Elliot axel
and Leslie
baharu and if you could just raise your
hands we would be able to pick you out
easily uh on our attendee list these are
all people who have pre-registered to
today repres Alexander would you be
willing to be our timer again
today uh yes I'll raise my hand in the
three
minutes Mr chairman yes i' just like to
request all the speakers including the
sponsors that have already spoken if you
have submitted testimony and writing
please let me know that when you come to
speak because it has to be annotated in
the minutes and it's really difficult
for me to go back and put on my emails
to find out if you're in
available
aher Mr Mr chair um if I may I believe
there's a state senator with her hands
raised um she's like
in the attendees list I'm not sure if
she wanted to testify but I wanted to
that
yes repres I'm sorry excuse this is rep
representative mcth are you speaking of
uh Senator Perkins Koka yes yes thank
you she is in the waiting to speak
chair
speak I do can you guys hear me
can okay thank you um good morning
chairman and members of the Judiciary
Committee for the record I Senator
Rebecca Perkins quoka from Senate
District 21 representing the city of
Portsmouth and the towns of Madbury Lee
Durham Newington New Market and
newfields I'm happy to be here with you
this morning and see so many of the
representatives from my
district I'm here to speak in opposition
to both bills in front of you today
concerning restrictions on
abortion now is a time to be expanding
access to healthcare our neighbors are
suffering and people are facing an
unprecedented housing and employment
crisis they do not need their rights
further jeopardized many facilities
which provide abortions provide other
medically necessary care and attempts to
liit limit Public Funding are well known
to be attempts to limit abortions and
have the collateral consequence of
disproportionately impacting communities
of color members of the lgbtq community
and lowincome
individuals abortion is a medically
necessary option though some of the
legislation before you today makes an
attempt to distinguish between medically
necessary and other abortions this is an
extremely complex decision that each
pregnant person should be allowed to
make
as a woman who was pregnant just over a
year ago it is a position of great
vulnerability and a time of great care
for the growing life inside of you no
pregnant person should face any barriers
in making a difficult decision that may
result from the significant condition of
being pregnant many complications to
pregnancy are simply heartbreaking and
we do not need politicians in the room
shaming pregnant people for decisions
which result from any natural process
respect pregnant people people and their
full ability to make their own decisions
the complexity of these pieces of
legislation simply belies how this is
around best left to our private citizens
and their qualified medical
professionals please vote in expedient
to legislate or itl on both of these
bills thank you for the opportunity to
speak and I'll be happy to answer any
questions you may have are there any
senator seeing then thank you for your
testimony today
thank
you the next person on the list was
Elliot
Christine you see
if I see a Christine yeah if she can
identify that she's the Christine
Arsenal I think just open it up I did so
Christine we can't hear you maybe you
unmute hi there I'm actually testifying
on the next bill it's this is Christine
wheelie okay different Christine you you
we saw your hand up so oh sorry I'm just
learning this the system here so thank
youe that thank you when you say the
Bahari
Canada how about MADD thank you oh I'm
here thank you thank you thank you
chairman Gordon and good morning members
of house Judiciary for the record my
name is Elizabeth Canada I live in exor
New Hampshire where I'm calling from I
am the advocacy manager at plan
Parenthood New Hampshire action fund and
plann Parenthood of Northern New England
we've submitted written testimony
opposing both House Bill 434 and 596 I'm
going to focus on House Bill 434 in my
testimony today we oppose House Bill 434
for two reasons first we oppose this
bill because it seeks to prohibit the
use of Medicaid insurance from covering
abortion care this already does not
happen in New Hampshire our state
already does not allow state Medicaid
insurance from going toward abortion
care and the H Amendment prohibits
Federal insurance from being used in any
way for abortion care in short patients
seeking an abortion must already pay for
their care out of pocket or use private
insurance that covers
abortion second we oppose this bill
because it would put in place a gag rule
on public colleges and University
campuses such as UNH this bill would ban
tuition and fees from funding on campus
health centers unless providers refuse
to make referrals for
abortion so what this bill does is
prohibit health clinics at our public
colleges and universities from providing
all options when patients face
unintended pregnancies including
information about or referrals for
abortion care this bill would prohibit
providers from giving their patients who
are our public college students the full
range of information that's a gag on
providers their alternative the position
this bill puts providers in is to offer
their patients all of the available
options but lose their funding in
tuition and fees and our state already
woefully underfunds higher
education this is an impossible and
unfair position to put our public
colleges and universities in and
extremely problematic when considering
Public Health wellness and safety for
our college students many of whom live
away from their childhood home and their
trusted home provider to sum up Medicaid
Insurance relied on by individuals who
are struggling financially already does
not cover abortion care and our New
Hampshire Public college and university
students should be able to trust that
their health centers on campus will
provide them complete and medically
accurate information no matter what
thank you for your time today and we ask
that you itl House Bill
434 thank you are there questions for
Miss
Canada seeing
thank you very much for your testimony
Mooney thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee are you able to hear me
we are perfect first of all I want to
thank all of you for your time and
attention over yesterday and today
you're certainly um dedicating
yourselves to some very important and
critical issues
issues my name is Moren money and I'm a
state representative for the town of
marac in Hillsboro County District
number 21 I'm a co-sponsor of House Bill
434 an act prohibiting the use of public
funds for abortion to be very clear I am
in support of House Bill
434 and I am only speaking this morning
on House Bill 430 for not any other
proposed
legislation this bill PR places practice
into law since the New Hampshire state
budget has repeatedly not allocated
public funds toward
abortions this bill places that
consistent practice into law New
Hampshire is one of 15 states that has
no law clarifying this matter with
approximately 23 States prohibiting
direct funding for elective
abortions therefore inserting the
practice of prohibiting public funds
toward abortion into state law clarifies
the
issue the Bill's findings cite a Supreme
Court case of rust versus
Sullivan in that case on a side note
Justice sudor New Hampshire's own cast
the deciding vote the US Supreme Court
made it clear that prohibiting public
funds toward abortion is
legal the majority on the court found
that not funding a previously determined
right does not prevent the right
itself or the right to express views on
it let's keep New Hampshire consistent
with practice I encourage you all to
vote ought to pass on House Bill
434 and I thank you again for your time
and attention that concludes my
testimony thank you are there any
questions for representative B oh yes
representative mlan uh thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative
Mooney for taking my question um one one
question or concern that was raised on a
similar Bill a few years back was let's
say that you had an individual um who
was incarcerated let's say for um a drug
offense so they're in jail and they
discover that they are pregnant and so
they want to exercise their right to an
abortion because of the ban in this bill
on facilities and the resources of the
State being involved the concern was how
could you transport that prisoner um to
the medical facility in order to get the
procedure since it would involve the the
resources of the state so under this
bill
434 how do you see that particular
scenario um being carried
out thank you for that
question uh that's not addressed
specifically
certainly um I would find it hard
pressed to think that a a prisoner would
be diagnosed on the spot uh in their
prison for for for a procedure or what
have you so I would think that a
transportation to a medical
facility uh would certainly be in order
um whether or not uh a public fund would
be involved there I'm I'm unsure but I
would think that certainly uh the
transportation would not be um an issue
to give a prisoner proper
medical
uh
Overlook representative mlan would you
like to follow up thank you Mr CH would
you be open to an amendment to maybe
clarify uh some of those
situations yes I would be very
language thank
you hey are there any other questions
for representative
money seeing none thank you for your
testimony today thank
you appears we also have another
representative representative toll who
testify good morning good morning my
name is Amanda Elizabeth tol I represent
Keen at large and I'm here today to
testify in opposition to HB 434 which
would prohibit the use of public funds
for abortions additionally it would deny
any public dollars from being used for
abortion related care this bill also
relates to education and youth rights as
students at public colleges would have
their relationship with campus Health
Services impacted since HB 434 would gag
on campus providers from giving
information on Full Spectrum
reproductive
healthare as a teenager I had an
unplanned pregnancy even as a privileged
young person with a family with monetary
resourcist I faced barriers to access
and Care in the process of finding an
abortion provider I accidentally called
a Crisis Pregnancy Center which gave me
misinformation about abortion and
traumatized me I also needed to notify
my parents which was a scary process
even though they are
pro-choice ultimately I did I did get an
abortion my abortion allowed me to go to
college and then to graduate school to
receive a master's in education I've
been able to own a small business teach
yoga and become a state representative
it allowed me to have when I was ready a
is
off looks like she's
muted we we did you hear me speak at all
we we lost you after you were telling us
that you were able to have a child okay
thank you so it allowed me to have when
I was ready a child who is now six in
the love of my life I'm leading the life
I want to be leading and I firmly
believe none of these things could have
happened if I was unable to have an
abortion having an abortion literally
saved my life maybe not my physical life
but the quality of my life as a result I
am passionate about preserving and
expanding access to reproductive health
care I know firsthand how important
access to this care can be one of the
things I find extremely disturbing about
this bill which impedes reproductive
Health Care access is that it will
impact those who are already the most
marginalized and struggle to gain access
to care Young Folks low-income folks
lgbtq plus folks and people of color
when public funds are limited the most
marginalized or impacted the most we
know that affluent white women will
always have access to reproductive
Health Care regardless of legal barriers
sharing my own abortion story for years
hearing the stories of others I know one
thing is for sure reproductive
Healthcare is an intersectional issue
people of all economic classes races and
religion access abortion care legal
barriers to abortion will not stop
abortions they will only keep the
disenfranchised folks from accessing the
care they need sometimes with deadly
results as legislators our goal should
be to expand access to care not to limit
it for these reasons I implore you to
vote against HB
434 I'm going to defer any questions to
you
[Music]
muted
rep representative toll did you submit
written
testimony uh I I did not but I can
submit this in writing I will submit it
in
writing thank you very
much okay so we're gonna be calling on
uh Dr Julia me next
then uh Jason Hennessy Jake
Barry Maddie Daniel Michael King and
Thomas Walton so if those individuals
could sign just raise their hands will
know that we are able to call upon them
us yep I'm here can you hear me now hear
you now okay excellent thank you um my
name is Dr Julia me I'm a medical doctor
I'm an OB obstetrician gynecologist I
live in Le New Hampshire I'm speaking
against House Bill 434 today I oppose
this
bill HB 434 signed to prohibit the use
of New Hampshire Medicaid for abortion
care but that doesn't happen in
Hampshire State Insurance already does
not cover abortion care furthermore the
height Amendment already bans the use of
federal insurance for abortion patients
getting abortion care have to use
private insurance if their plan covers
it or pay out of pocket thing is
Medicaid funded abortion care in the
state of New Hamp New
Hampshire another harmful piece of this
legislation would be to Institute a gag
rule on Healthcare Providers at New
Hampshire's public colleges and
universities would prevent them from
providing all options to students
including referrals to for abortion care
for the state government to step into
the provider's office and dictate the
limits of patient care is wrong I care
for my patients best in evidence-based
practice and providing patients with all
of the facts I then allow my patients to
take make medical decisions for
themselves using my knowledge as a
resource But ultimately letting them
make decisions about their own bodies
hiding information from patients about
routine necessary reproductive health
care such as abortion care violates
medical ethics and it puts government
legislation in between the doctor
patient
relationship this relationship is
private it's based on trust and it
should be protected rather than
regulated the purpose of bill is to make
it harder for people to access routine
reproductive Health Care such as
abortion and it specifically targets
lowincome people college students people
of color and Rural people who already
face barriers um and difficulty
obtaining the healthcare that they need
this bill is wrong for the people of New
Hampshire who respectfully urge you to
oppose HB 434 thank
me seeing none thank you very much for
today have um Jason
Hennessy
thank you Mr chair can everybody hear me
can all right honorable members of the
House Judiciary Committee thank you for
your time my name is Jason Hennessy I'm
a resident of Amherst New Hampshire I'm
also the president of New Hampshire
right to life I'm here to speak in
support of House Bill 434 and House Bill
596 yesterday uh in the hearing for the
viability protection I ask you to
consider two
questions the first one is who is a
person and the second one is what
protections do those uh persons
deserve today now I ask you to consider
those questions from the perspective of
the hundreds of thousands of New
Hampshire residents whose religious and
moral teachings tell them that abortion
is
wrong um the issue you have before you
today is not whether abortion is legal
but whether you want to Force other
people to support these with their tax
dollars I submit to you that that
forcing forcing people who are pro-life
to support abortion with their tax
dollars is no different from China that
forces Muslim Wagers to eat
pork or forcing anti-slavery
abolitionists to subsidize slavery
through the fugitive slave laws in other
words these are things that are
completely against our our moral and our
beliefs um these bills do not limit
abortion in any
way instead they instead all they do is
they say that we we won't use the common
tax dollars to support them for the many
for the many folks who are speaking in
favor or against this bill in favor of
taxpayer subsidies um I would like to
refer them that there are several
nonprofit abortion providers in New
Hampshire and that they're very welcome
to make donations to them uh with that I
I would um appreciate it if you would
support these bills and would love any
questions thank you any questions from
Mr
Hennessy seeing none thank you for your
testimony
today is Jake Barry
available I do not see him on the list
okay sorry good morning Mr chairman can
you hear me all right can yes wonderful
uh Mr chairman honorable members of the
committee my name is Jake Barry I'm the
vice president of policy of new Futures
as many of you know new Futures is a
nonpartisan nonprofit Health policy and
advocacy organization we work to
increase access to quality affordable
health care and to improve Health Equity
all across our state I have submitted
written testimony and I do I don't want
to repeat too much of what we've
included there but I do want to
emphasize new future strong opposition
to both uh House Bill 434 and
596 parts of these bills including the
ban on Medicaid from covering abortion
services are redundant in unnecessary as
we've heard today moreover these bills
are harmful and threatened to severely
impact the health and wellness of our
state and our people we believe as has
been stated by others that reproductive
health is a key part of our system of
care and access to reproductive care and
counseling is critical to supporting the
health and wellness of our state into
the future this is certainly true for
the students who would be impacted by
the so called gag rule proposed under
house bill 434 if instituted this gag
rule would violate medical ethics and
standards of care and it would create a
wedge between a patient and healthc care
provider threatening to limit the care
available to students enrolled in our
public institutions at a time when they
need it most more broadly the
prohibitions proposed under these bills
threaten to undermine the long-term
health of our children and families
studies show studies from throughout the
country show that denial of abortion can
have significant Health social and
economic implications that can harm
women and children for years uh as
you've heard today the decision to have
an abort abortion is already one of the
most difficult choices a woman in a
family will ever have to make to pass
these bills would just make that process
even more more traumatic and could have
long-term impacts on the health and
wellness of our family and our state so
we would ask you to uh vote both of
these bills and expedience to legislate
thank you very
Barry if not thank thank you your
testimony Mr
Barry next person uh I do not see
Michael
Daniel hello can you hear me we
can awesome thank you Mr chairman thank
you for letting me testify for the house
Judiciary Committee and opposition to
house bills 596 in 434 my name is Maddie
Daniel and I'm actually testifying on
behalf of another one of the members of
the New Hampshire High School Democrats
who is very passionate about this issue
but unfortunately could not be here
today in her testimony she writes the
following I am testifying in opposition
to HB 596 in 434 because as a woman who
was a Christian this bill opposes the
separation of church and state which is
something that has real value in
upholding The credibility of our New
Hampshire government I am aware that a
Christian should be considered pro life
since abortion is sinful rather though I
am pro-choice because I believe that
everyone regardless of their religion
gender race Etc should have affordable
access to this medical service based on
what I've heard abortion is never an
easy decision and from my experience not
one that a woman take slightly if a
woman is to make this decision they
should have access to the essential
services that are necessary in order to
access a safe and legal abortion it is
the right of public companies to do so
and provide these Services regardless of
their opinions on the issue and the same
goes for the government according to
Planned Parenthood abortion prices are
up to go up to $1,000 reason behind
getting an abortion are varied but all
are valid some factors that play into
such an important decision include your
health insurance your income and
financial support programs available in
your area the type of abortion you get
and how far along your pregnancy is
according to data gathered by AARP the
average health insurance cost for single
coverage premiums in 2020 is $388 per
month and the average New Hampshire
woman earns
$2,368 a month if a woman has to spend
$11,000 on an abortion in New Hampshire
and is making a minimum wage salary that
puts her with little other resources for
rent health care and other necessary
utilities I implore members to support
subsidized abortion and conceptive
services rather than allowing women to
struggle to pay for the treatment
themselves especially when their health
is on the line I would also like to add
that over 66% of New Hampshire adults
support abortion services and public
dollar should represent the interests of
the people now is the time to be
expanding Healthcare versus shutting it
down thank you for your time and I urge
you to itl these bills no questions
please thank you very much for your
Walton yes there he is do you see him
yep
Walton thank you Mr chairman my name is
Thomas Walton I'm president of two
companies in Southern New Hampshire
which I started 25 years ago if I had to
do it again I would not start these
companies in New Hampshire for two
reasons the first reason is the the
total fertility rate in New Hampshire
now is the lowest in the country I think
only Vermont and the District of
Colombia have lower fertility rates
we're now at 1.5 and dropping not even
China has got that low China at its
lowest had a total fertility rate of 1.6
in 2000 uh they now are going up up as
their economy uh their Manufacturing
Powerhouse tends to
increase New Hampshire is continuing to
slip in this very low fertility rate how
is a
company you know supposed to get their
future
employees with a total fertility rate
that low I for one am one of seven
children my mother and father under very
uh limited Circumstances had us mainly
as a loving sacrifice which is what
children are they're always a loving
sacrifice we were taught very well uh
and gained the ambition to do what we
did now to make companies like my own we
need to improve on our fertility rate
it's killing us New Hampshire and
Vermont and the District Columbia are
now lowest in the
country near lowest in the world we need
to improve for utility rates thank
you thank you for your testimony today
representative Horgan did you have a
question sure yes thank you very much Mr
chair thank Mr Walton
um these two bills deal only with um
abortion except for a little thing about
foster children and Adoption Fund so
um this would probably be a very
different Bill and a different committee
but you support uh you have any
suggestions for things we can do to make
it easier for uh families to raise raise
children and to attract you know young
younger younger people of childbearing
here yes I realize for young people
especially young unmarried uh women
especially this is uh assaulting them at
the weakest points in their lives and in
that case
especially uh at adoption services uh
Foster uh foster parents they are always
available and as you know many are the
the the kindest and best parents that a
child could possibly have those types of
services are where we should be putting
most of our efforts in most case it
takes no effort it's a charitable
sacrifice of these adopted uh parents
and foster parents who are opening they
open their arms for these types of
children and this always there's always
a choice it's always better for the
mother no matter what circumstances
they're
in
followup I just
yes um so do you have any suggestions on
what we do to make it easier for you
know the young women to actually and
they and the fathers of these babies
actually raise a child like they put
more money into child care for working
parents or PID family medical leave or
more money for education so you have any
suggestions while we're sitting here
listening to you um thank
you yes is as uh as president of two
successful companies I've got 35 Plus
employees uh they're all thriving uh I'm
glad I didn't move out my my plan uh
when things were getting much worse uh
with a lot of thanks to the
international Planned Parenthood uh
Juggernaut as I call it which is
destroyed politics in our
state the the changes have have just
gotten worse and worse uh the
manufacturing that China is an example
has brought 800 million people out of
poverty with that manufacturing
Juggernaut is the same type of
manufacturing Juggernaut that Alexander
Hamilton used as a as an example to get
our economy and good jobs millions of
good jobs well-paying jobs that Inspire
families to to to sacrifice for their
their children because they know there's
there's a future there now some as you
well known as as you will know have
tried to reignite that manufacturing
Juggernaut which we need more than ever
right now and it's been put on temporary
delay for a couple years but believe me
it's coming back people know where where
where we lost out some 30 40 years ago
as manufacturing jobs got shipped
overseas but once they come back the
it okay any other
questions Mr
w sing n thank you for your testimony
today thank
you uh the next set of speakers will be
uh Jane hay
Christine
wheel uh Jean
rusa shashana
Kelly and Kate
Maloney and is Jane hag available and
please if I just called your name please
raise your hand so we know where you
Christine wheel and I'm not sure I'm
e yes we that must be the other
morning
yep hi there my name is Christine
wheelie I am the founder of one heart
Ministries Minnesota and I am in support
of um Bill
596 um I actually um I'm speaking on
behalf of the Ministries and churches I
I'm from Minnesota but I actually work
with u multiple different organizations
right to life and we do all the same
things partnering and on behalf of the
Ministries and
churches support this bill um you know I
Stand For Life actually I am uh my
mother chose life for me at the age of
14 she was homeless on the street and uh
at that age she chose life and and um
here I am today and on behalf of um you
know Millions Across America who want to
see the taxpayer dollars out of Planned
Parenthood um I'm just a voice for those
as well and um I just ask that you
support this bill I also like this bill
um because it does go further than the
previous one um in the support of
adoption funding um I personally work
with um many different organizations who
um give the option of adoption as well
um you know I was actually my father
adopted me um my mom like I said chose
life at 14 years old um it was
organizations that um gave her resources
as a young young girl to um pave the way
for me to be here education awareness um
you know just being a basic Mo you know
mother at that age um the next year she
did not choose life you know so I could
have been aborted um and you know today
um it's just an honor to be here with
you all and uh just share that um I'm
just one of many many people I do work
with women and families in crisis um I
also work with those on campuses there's
uh Ministries and organizations on
campuses that will support the choice of
an unplanned pregnancy uh no no
pregnancy is really planned um you know
and there are um just many reasons why
it's important to um support this and um
yeah so I just wanted to just thank you
guys for the opportunity just to share
briefly um
why I believe it's important to stand
for life and um and remove the taxpayer
dollars
from uh supporting Planned Parenthood
and other organizations because there
are other options um especially in this
time that we're living in right now um
on campuses and across you know people
have become awakened to the fact that
there is help and uh counseling for
those people who um do have um unplanned
pregnancies so thank you so much thank
you for your testimony are there any
wheel seeing none again thank you for
your testimony
rusa good morning thank you Mr chair and
members of the committee my name is
Jeanie hesa and I'm the political
director for the American civil
liberties Union of New Hampshire I
appreciate the opportunity to testify to
today in opposition to both HB 596 and
HB
434 in truth I struggle honestly to
comprehend HB 596 with its references to
quote nonsecular Shams non-controversial
transcultural
morality and the offensive idea of a
quote convenience abortion this bill
garbles the law and wrongly asserts that
Public Funding for abortion violates the
First Amendment
public funds are used every day for
services and undertakings with which
members of the public disagree this
includes paying for war incarceration
and even vaccinations on which the
government is currently spending
billions without any infringement on the
First Amendment taxpayers do not get to
direct or restrict their tax payments
according to their beliefs if they did I
expect there are a number of federal
departments that would have
significantly fewer funds than they do
today on HB
434 this bill is Extreme as the prime
sponsor noted it includes a very narrow
exception for the physical health of the
pregnant person excluding coverage for
people who become pregnant due to rape
or incest and the narrow exception
excludes coverage for abortion Services
necessary for the emotional or
psychological health of the mother or
other health considerations as
determined by a doctor
I also want to be very clear that HB 434
would have little to no impact on people
with financial
means this bill instead takes direct aim
at marginalized people it discriminates
against low income individuals and
singles them out by denying them Medical
Care Public Funding restrictions leave
some people little choice but to use
money they need for food rent clothing
or other necessities to pay for an
abortion moreover many low-income people
are forced to delay their abortions in
an effort to save up the money needed
for the medical care increasing their
medical risks additionally we share the
previous concerns expressed about how
this bill would impose a gag rule on
public institutions of Higher Learning
by prohibiting them from using any
tuition or fees to make even a referral
for
abortion I will submit my testimony in
writing and for these reasons I
respectfully ask the members of this
committee to vote itl on both of these
bills thank
rusa singan thank you for your testimony
today thank
Kelly I
Kate
Maloney can you hear me we can awesome
thank you um hello members of the New
Hampshire State Judiciary my name is
Kate Maloney and I am the New England
regional coordinator for students for
life of America I am here today to
represent the pro-life interest for the
students of New Hampshire I support
House Bill 434 and House Bill 596 I
strongly urge you to support House Bill
434 and House Bill 596 recently students
for life of America's Institute for
pro-life advancement released a poll and
found that seven out of 10 Millennials
and genz want to vote on abortion
related policy more than seven out of 10
express support for limits on abortion
and almost five in 10 do not support
forcing all Americans regardless of
their beliefs to pay for abortions in a
state where abortion access is unlimited
and where abortion facilities are not
inspected by the Department of Health it
is in this legislator's best interest to
respect the consciousness of its
taxpayers to ensure that public funds
are not used for abortions New Hampshire
has numerous options for women who are
facing an unplanned pregnancy there are
federally qualified Healthcare centers
which outnumber Planned Parenthood 16
to1 and also outnumber Planned
Parenthood Services preg pregnancy he
centers which offer free ultrasounds
pregnancy tests and material assistance
and maternity homes that are there to
support and enrich the individual not
profit from them students for life has
an initiative called standing with you
to provide parents and panting and
parenting students with information on
resources available to them having funds
allocated for foster care and adoption
initiatives will build a culture of life
in New Hampshire that serves the
community by recognizing the Dignity of
every human
person New Hampshire has consistently
withheld public funds for from abortion
and should continue to do so because
pregnancy is not a disease cured by
abortion if your Healthcare kills people
on purpose you're doing it wrong in
conclusion I urge you to support the
passage of House Bill 434 and 596 and to
continue the legacy of funding life
affirming non-violent Healthcare options
for women thank you for your
time do you have any written
testimony I do and I can submit it thank
you very much you're very
welcome are there any questions from
Miss
Maloney
seeing n thank you again for your
testimony today the next people to be
called will be Jessica Morgan Josie
Spencer and if they could raise their
helpful is Jessica Morgan
Pinto good morning thank you all for
having me uh my name is Josie Pinto I
live in Dober and I'm here on behalf of
myself this morning to express my
opposition to both of these bills I want
to make it clear that we do not need
this bill as it currently stands here in
New Hampshire we do not have Public
Funding for abortions if we did I
wouldn't have had to have countless
phone calls with patients who have no
idea how they're going to pay for their
abortion when I previously worked at one
of New Hampshire's abortion providers
those calls broke my heart and they
committed me to a lifelong fight of
insuring abortions remain accessible I'm
actually in full support of Public
Funding of abortions it should not be
the one medical procedure where patients
are told they can't receive funding if
they're on Medicaid when many private
insurances do cover it this is blatant
discrimination of those facing the
challenge of already being in poverty
many of whom are already parents Studies
have shown that nearly 40% of people
cannot cover a sudden $400 expense which
is exactly what an abortion is for many
people if not more than that people
deserve the care they need regardless of
their ability to pay parenting should be
a choice that people make when it's
right for them not something they're
forced into when money is already tight
lastly as a young person who is suppor
reported friends getting abortions
during my time in college I believe we
need to work to expand abortion access
for college students not provide
unnecessary gag
rules uh thank you so much for hearing
me today I really really encourage you
to vote itl on both of these bills and
thank you thank you any questions for
Miss
Pinto seeing none thank you for your
testimony
Spencer
hello um thank you Mr chair for taking
my testimony today and thank you to the
members of this committee uh my name is
Louise Spencer I live in conquer and I
am speaking on my own behalf today
opposing both of these bills and urging
uh the committee to vote this uh both of
these bills
itl um I will defer much of what I was
going to say because because uh we heard
such excellent testimony today from
others who are opposed to these bills I
just would like to highlight the concern
about the gag rule and the fact that um
this will seriously
impact the ability of students at
particularly at public universities to
have full and complete information
regarding the range of Medical Services
is that are available to them should
they uh find themselves facing a
pregnancy that they had not uh planned
on this is particularly concerning when
we look at the numbers of rapes at on
college campuses we know that you know
at a minimum it's 133% of women have uh
conveyed that they have experienced a
sexual assault or rape
while at college and it is in one recent
study as high as one in Four Women uh
the fact that someone could experience
this sort of trauma and not be able to
get access to the full range of
information needed to determine how to
move forward is particularly
disturbing uh when you consider that
that information may be limited by a
woman's ability to to pay to have the
financial resources to get information I
was struck by the last um witness
testifying in favor of the bill um it
seems to me quite unfair that money can
be spent at clinics that provide only
partial information to patients and yet
cannot be spent at clinics that provide
women with the full range of choices
that are legal and should be available
to them um so with that I would just
once again reiterate my strong um
request that both of these bills be ited
um and I would just say that I I find it
disingenuous when I hear um from a
sponsor of a bill that this is not about
limiting abortion I think it's better
when we are clear about what we really
are intending to do here and that we
address that issue right out in the open
and not claim that we are only trying to
prevent public dollars from being spent
on abortions um so thank you very much
thank you for your testimony are there
Spencer see none again thank you for
testifying
today that um with regard to those who
have pre-registered we only have three
more people who have in fact
pre-registered
West Andy
Pelosi actually four people Steph George
and Kelsey v
v and if you could raise your hands that
today do not see
Sarah but I see Steph George so Steph
testify hi thank you um good morning my
name is Stephanie George I live in do
New Hampshire where I'm calling from
today and I'm here to voice my
opposition to House Bill
abortion is a safe and legal medical
procedure and in 1973 it was ruled that
a pregnant woman has the Liberty to
choose an abortion without excessive
government restriction I cannot perceive
House Bill 596 as anything other than
excessive government restriction every
person ought to be able to get the
health care they need including abortion
based on what's best for their unique
needs not politics but bills like House
Bill 5
966 seek to put up Financial barriers
between an individual and their
doctor however we feel personally about
abortion politicians should not be
allowed to deny health coverage to an
individual just because they're poor
when Medicaid covers the cost of all
Pregnancy Care including abortion it
means someone can make decisions based
on what is best for their unique
circumstances it should also be noted as
previously stated that the hide
Amendment already prohibits hits Federal
Medicaid money from going towards
abortion and every year New Hampshire
anti-abortion politicians vote to
prohibit State Medicaid funding from
going towards abortion bills like House
Bill 596 seek to make such a ban
permanent effectively ensuring that
lowincome people in our state will
continue to receive subpar medical care
that is meddled with by the government
there is absolutely no medical purpose
for band Lake House Bill 596 leaving
government interference as the with
people's private lives as the only
identifiable goal I and many other
Granite Staters stand in strong
opposition to this bill and all bills
like it and I urge you to vote against
it thank you for your time thank you
George thank you Miss George for your
testimony
available
available that concludes the list of
people who pre-registered to speak here
today if there are other people who do
wish to speak you could uh raise your
hand we will call upon you there's
someone who's been waiting peers for a
seier yes Mr yes Mr chairman uh thank
you so much for having me um members of
the committee so I'm a uh former Judge
Advocate General assistant United States
attorne Attorney we uh I've provided
written
testimony uh I'm here to testify in
favor of um House Bill 596 uh over for
uh House Bill 434 we support the intent
of House Bill 434 but submit and and
those that Prov provideed it submit that
the uh constitutionality of 596 is uh
reflects what article six of the New
Hampshire Constitution requires as well
as the um First Amendment of the United
States
Constitution basically uh House Bill 596
is predicated on the idea that when
someone says that life doesn't begin a
conception that abortion isn't a world
that it's not um murder those are a
series of unproven faith-based
assumptions and necked assertions that
are implicitly religious and inseparably
linked to the religion of secular
humanism the Supreme Court starting in
Tazo versus Watkins followed by Seager
followed by the wells case just about
every single federal court of appeals
has found that secular humanism is a
religion for the purpose of the First
Amendment including The Establishment
Clause The Establishment Clause is the
provision of the first amendment that
prohibits the government from entangling
itself with a religious ideology it
takes a lot of a a lot of religious
Faith to believe that convenience
abortion practices aren't modern day
child sacrific on the altar of
convenience so basically what 596 is
saying is it saying this it's saying
pursuant to article six of the New
Hampshire Constitution as well as the
first amendment Establishment Clause of
the United States Constitution the state
of New Hampshire whether anyone
regardless of anyone's emotional
feelings is prohibited from
appropriating a penny of public state or
federal taxpayer dollars to convenience
abortions convenience abortions involves
abortions that don't involve incest or
um when the mother's lives in danger
because that appropriation is not fails
what's called prongs one and three of
the Limon test the Limon test is a test
used we use in federal district court to
determine whether or not government
action violates The Establishment Clause
if Government action fails one prong of
lemon is unconstitutional that
appropriation fails at least two prongs
of lemon because number one it lacks a
primary secular purpose it is a sham it
is basically advancing modern day child
sacrifice onone the the alar of
convenience I know other people feel
otherwise uh but we're not really trying
to prove or disprove whether or not life
begins at conception we're just saying
that it's dispro it's not proven
therefore it falls within this the
jurisdiction of The Establishment Clause
and then thirdly secondly it constitutes
what's called an excessive entanglement
with the religion of secular humanism so
that's kind of the legal framework
behind the bill that we've written out
of an enormous about a multi-state
federal litigation but let me make the
argument for House Bill 596 in plain
English basically the way this bill is
going is it says in every District in
this state whether it's blue or red
there is at least one taxpayer who
sincerely believes that abortion
practices are immoral and it also
follows that they believe that to enable
acts of immorality is itself an act of
immorality and
therefore according to this bill this
state is proh must be prohibited from
appropriating public funds to
convenience abortion providers because
it causes it coer ly causes those
taxpayers to violate their own
conscience by the simple Act of paying
taxes it's an evil that article six of
the New Hampshire Constitution as well
as the first amendment Establishment
Clause of the United States Constitution
was designed to prohibit so now let me
quickly just address the differences
between 493 and and 596 the enforcement
mechanisms of 596 are vastly superior uh
because they allow taxpayers to have
standing to bring a lawsuit where they
can have seek attorneys fees and they
can seek adjunctive relief to stop State
actor from appropriating public funds to
convenience abortion providers it also
creates what's called adoption and
Foster Care initiative fund and um which
where public funds money that otherwise
would have gone to convenience abortion
providers can go to that fund and
moreover if an abortion provider is fine
the the state legislature would have the
opportunity to put money in that fund
because adoption funding and Foster Care
funding are secular in nature Mr SE I
don't want to cut you off but we do have
a three minute limit on test yes sir and
then um that that I can I can stop with
that if you'd like me to I'd be welcome
to answer any questions any of the
members might have well just one one
question for me and that is your
argument seems to be quite complex so I
guess I would ask whether or not you
have submitted written testimony yeah
I'm so sorry we have submitted written
testimony we have indeed yes sir I
should have said that first I'm sorry
about that is it we is that you have
submitted it or is there some
organization there's def fact there's
about there's about eight organizations
signed under to that there's deao
Attorneys General there's special forces
of Liberty there's several different
ministers to just to name some of the
different ones there's Garden State
families there's another thing to say is
that multitudes of other states are
running the language of 596 they passed
some general provision they reflect
anyway so yeah that's yes yes M Mr
chairman that's we submitted WR
testimony representative Simpson did you
question you're
muted thank you I I do I had two but you
asked one already so um the other one uh
sorry it went by so
fast
um okay I think what I'm trying to ask
is um you just mentioned in 596 is in a
lot of other states and I'm just
wondering if the if you can point us to
somewhere for more information on that
and where that is when we go to study
before we vote and then um the F my the
second part of that is did you help
write 596 is that one of the things that
your groups do well so in the N case
we're Federal litigators who are lawyers
that know just enough to be dangerous on
any topic but we do follow a lot of
federal lawsuit in the instant case here
president Trump withheld $60 million
that would have otherwise gone through
title 10 to plan Parenthood our team
moved to intervene in that case it was
California versus HHS really versus the
Trump Administration it's from that
fighting that a lot of the language
emerged but there's a Ser there's a m
there's multitudes of cases that have
been filed on different topics where the
language has been written we would
respectfully submit that really it's the
advice and suggestions of kind of the
originalist judges who've made different
statements that were were basically the
primary off of the bill we kind of
assembled some of that language but uh
it was put together um by a numerous
constitutional law professors is federal
litigators and uh just to you know just
to reflect what the Constitution
requires the important thing to note is
that the bill it narrowly deals with
whether the Constitution and in of New
Hampshire and whether the state the
Federal Constitution allows Republic
funds to go to convenience abortion
providers it has nothing to do with
limiting at the time of abortion not
fetal heartbeat paying capable or none
nothing like that so there's the answer
to that and in terms of the other other
question about other people who were uh
introducing the bill there's
representative Ben in South Carolina
who's introduced the bill I can't
remember the bill number I think it's
3508 it's h358 but I can get that
information but it's representative
Bennett the representative Samson in
Maine is carrying the bill uh
representative um assemblyman o in New
Hampshire is carrying the bill um and
then I'm just trying to think of groups
near it's assembly men D Petro in New
York uh it would be representative
Reagan in Tennessee it'd be Senator
Carlin in Iowa it'd be representative
Leaf in Oregon it'd be representative
Clifford in Washington there's a lot I
could keep going but I mean the point is
is that multitudes of states are are
basically amending what is 434 and again
we we really respect those people behind
that bill and appreciate appreciate that
and we would it you know respectfully
request that the submit committee vote
in favor of both of those bills but we
definitely favor 596 because a lot of
other states are amending a general pro
prohibition against public funds going
into conveni abortion providers and are
using this new language so sorry yes sir
yes Mr chair representative Alexander
did you have a
question um yeah two Mr Sheriff um
you'll indulge me um um thank you for
taking my questions um first of all I'm
wondering so this seems like it's a
national effort I'm wondering
specifically are you a New Hampshire
resident and then my second question is
are you currently a practicing attorney
so the answer is that say I'm currently
a practicing attorney lead counsel in a
few cases in federal district court
right now uh
secondly the United States is a
constitutional republic New Hampshire is
part of the con is part of that
required to obey the Federal
Constitution representative pleats Bill
596 reflects what the First Amendment of
the United States Constitution requires
basically the argument is that nobody in
New Hampshire no taxpayers want their
money go that are that oppose abortion
or believe that it's murder do they
don't want their money taxpayer dollars
going to convenience abortion providers
because it causes taxpayers to feel like
they have blood on their hands so we're
not saying you can't have an abortion
you can have it you just have to pay for
it for it yourself and so I think you
answered the
question that was asked I did I answer
it I did not I a lawyer sorry so
basically I you know I we spent a lot of
time in New Hampshire we work with a lot
of groups in New Hampshire there's a lot
of pastors and groups in New Hampshire
that are not subject matter experts on
constitutional jurist prudence and so
they've asked us to help with this and
so as advocates we are representing some
of those kind of individual pastors
individual church members and so forth
Christine wheel is a colleague of mine
that was one of those is another member
that works with a lot of those
organizations that might not you know I
went to vanderbelt undergrad Vanderbilt
law school was a Judge Advocate General
and they might not understand First
Amendment jurist Prudence thank you I
think you answered the question that was
asked
yes sir yes Mr chairman representative
Simpson did you did I cut you off did
you have a followup question at
all no sir I was just saying thank you
thank you and representative Oregan did
you have a
question um I had several but I think
even though I feel like I've been
drinking from a fire hose I think I did
hear answers to my question in his
responses about Reverend simpsons's
rever Alexander's questions and I think
he also answered the question that I
asked representative plet uh it seems
like many years ago but now hour and a
half ago so I'm all set thanks okay
thank you representative Langley
representative Langley did you have a
question I did thank you Mr chair could
you you you have used the term
frequently convenience abortion could
you help me understand who determines
whether it's a convenience or not is
that the physician the individual the
clinic um who who decides whether the
abortion is convenient or not uh yes
representative basically convenience
abortion is just a term of art it also
could be referred to as a
non-therapeutic abortion sometimes in
court we call it an elective abortion
it's just it's just it's just a scenario
where you know someone's been has a
pregnancy and they they just want to get
rid of it you know that that's there's a
distinction we we we the bill rep draws
a distinction between what's called a
secular abortion and a nonsecular
abortion secular abortion is basically
you know if the mother's Liv's in danger
if it's the product of rape or if it's
the product of incest there's legal
principles that kick in like the
transferred right of self-defense the
right of self-defense for a mother if
she was dying and it was the choice
between her or the child she could you
know make that decision to abort the
child and the state could fund an
abortion practice like that the state
could fun fund an abortion practice if
it was the productive rape if there was
a police report involved that's a major
difference with the distinction versus
just someone who has a baby gets
pregnant and wants to abort it again
there's a lot of people who have
testified today who really believe that
those practices constitutes a for that
or immoral and more likely than not
might be murder and they just don't want
to have anything to do with that and so
that's the difference with the
distinction between a secular abortion
and a non-secular abortion the question
presented for for the members here is
determine whether or not such an
appropriation would be a secular
appropriation or nonsecular
representative PL section of the bill
that deals with adoption and Foster Care
deals with those would be a secular
Appropriations because states have
compelling interest to do things like
aold Community standards of decency and
to not promote Lous and the
appropriation towards abortion promotes
licentiousness and erods Comm Community
stands of decency those are difference
with distinctions yes ma'am
yes thank you for your response are
seier thank you for your testimony today
yes thank you members of the committee
very much thank you for what you're
doing okay
Antman hello can you hear
me thank you uh good morning committee
members thank you for your time today my
name is Alyssa Antman I'm in conquered
New Hampshire and I'm speaking on behalf
of myself and my younger sister Talia
Antman who could not share her testimony
today in opposition to HB 434 I've also
submitted this as written testimony as
well thank you yeah um Talia is an
incredibly bright full-time student
studying social work at the University
of New Hampshire and is working two jobs
to help pay for her education she cannot
testify today because she's currently
working a shift right now because our
parents are small business owners and
healthcare for dependents is cost
prohibitive talia's health insurance and
Health Services are directly through UNH
here is her testimony quote campus
health services are the only accessible
providers for me and students like me HP
434 would adversely and directly impact
those of us who are college students at
public universities who rely on these
Health Services on campus by instituting
a gag rule on Healthcare this gag roll
would prevent our oncampus providers
from explaining all reproductive Health
Options to us including information
about or referrals for abortion care
when I go to the Health Center at UNH I
need to be able to trust that I'm given
complete medically accurate information
especially during this pandemic as
Healthcare is even harder to access I
rely on this care more than ever and
need to know all of my options
I strongly oppose HP 434 as it
interferes with the relationship I have
with my doctor and the care I receive at
un end quote I stand with my sister and
other college students at public
colleges and universities as an alumnist
of unh Healthcare Services on campus
were vital to me especially knowing all
of my reproductive Healthcare options as
an older sister I want Talia to have
access to that same level of care I
respectfully urge you to vote against HP
434 thank you again for your time thank
you for your testimony are there any
questions for
Miss see again thank you for testifying
here
today
AER hello Mr chairman can you hear me we
can thank you very much my name is uh
Christopher Ager I'm from Amhurst New
Hampshire representing my myself and I
support House Bill
434 and oppose House Bill
596 I think that's a reasonable approach
for the committee to take my primary
concern is um taxpayer funding uh for a
procedure that many of us believe um is
is a violation of our conscience and I
also have one anecdote of a woman who
was pressured to have an abortion and it
was made on her we never want to see
that happen um but again my primary
concern is support for 434 and not
forcing people of conscience to pay for
something they believe is is morally
wrong thank you very much and thank you
for all the work that you do on the
committee thank you for your testimony
Mr AER are there any questions for Mr
Agger see
May hi everyone can you hear me we can
okay thank you for having me today
members um chairman I appreciate your
time and I appreciate you hearing me out
um yesterday I was on errands when I
testified quickly about being on the
sidewalks and conquered and in
Manchester and the opportunity I have
had to help people I have even had fa a
father come up to me and thank me and
thank others at KET for the parenting
classes he had
um let's see I want to start off with
Proverbs 318 to9 God says in the Bible
the Holy Bible speak out on behalf of
the voiceless and for the rights of all
who are vulnerable speak speak out in
order to judge to defend righteously the
needy and poor I represent not only the
pro-life Community but many churches I
represent girls who have been pressured
into abortion I'm sanctity and value of
life is important and as you can tell my
voice is a little shaky and that is
because this is so personal to me and I
am so passionate to fight for baby
helpless baby
all of my life until the day I die I say
you want to take a baby's life hit me
first because I am here for children
next I'd like to say I'm in support of
HB
596 the reason why I'm in support of
these
bills is
because first of all it's
immoral it's immoral to kill a baby and
I believe believe the state has an
obligation when it comes to the bottom
line to fight for life um and if you do
not support this you are also guilty of
murder so I'm just going to say that for
today thank
you okay thank you for your testimony
are there any questions from Miss
May seeing none move on to our next
good morning Mr chairman can you hear me
we can thank you Ian hwit appearing on
behalf of Cornerstone and my testimony
this morning is limited to house bill
for
434 Cornerstone supports 434 together
with representative xen's proposed
amendment the bill codifies that state
funds won't be used to directly Finance
or promote abortion at the same time the
proposed amendment will prevent the bill
from inviting an abstract legal fight
like the one that occurred in the
Supreme Court case Dalton against Little
Rock Family Planning overall the Bill's
text means that New Hampshire will
refrain from funding abortion to the
extent permitted by federal law I
believe most of the people who
criticized for 434 this morning um did
not hear representative Sheen statement
about her proposed amendment but some of
the other two criticisms that we heard
that were recurring were first that the
bill seeks to prevent something that
isn't happening and second that the Bill
acts as a gag order on public
institutions by denying funds for
abortion so the first point is actually
consistent with representative shien's
stated goals for the bill she seeks only
to prevent abortion from being publicly
funded but the second point I think
misconceives what the US Constitution
requires um and anecdotally just because
I'm a lawyer and I'm interested in
challenging the government sometimes
I'll have um parents will approach me
and they'll express interest in suing
their school district because they
perceive that there's Progressive
political bias in the district's
curriculum and whenever this happens I
always have to explain that political
bias in the government's messaging is
not a legal cause of action the Supreme
Court pointed out in Rust against
Sullivan when Congress established the
National Endowment for democracy quote
it was not constitutionally required to
fund a program to encourage competing
lines of political philosophy unquote so
the government's free constitutionally
to adopt a particular message and it
can't coer us into espousing that
message but it does not need to directly
subsidize speech that it disagrees with
and for exactly the same reasons it's
not required to subsidize either
abortion or abortion referrals even
though both of those things are legally
protected by constitutional uh case law
in Rust which is a case that attorney
Mooney also mentioned the Supreme Court
directly considered whether the
government could refuse to fund abortion
referrals as part of its title 10
program the court appell the regulations
prohibiting funding of those referrals
saying that they did not quote Force the
title 10 grantee to give up abortion
related speech they merely required that
the grantee keep such activities
separate and distinct from publicly
funded
activities and exactly the same thing is
true of this bill this bill only directs
how the government's money is spent and
it does not place a gag order on anyone
this bill is a common sense extension of
the general Court's budgetary practices
in multiple fiscal years as
representative Gan pointed out and I'm
happy to answer any questions about
either the bill as a whole or the
proposed amendment are there any
hu seeing none thank you for your
Banis
hi can you guys hear me okay can hear
you great so good morning committee
members thank you for your time today
and for hearing my testimony my name is
Olivia balabanis I'm a student at UNH
and I'm speaking in opposition to HB
434 this is an extreme bill that impedes
reproductive Health Care access for
public colleges and
universities as a college student I know
that my peers who rely most on this care
will be most negatively impacted by this
poor legislation our UNH Health and
Wellness Center is the only accessible
health care provider for many students
living on and around campus myself
included students already facing immense
challenges especially during a pandemic
will be most affected including those
with low income lgbtq plus individuals
and students of color during a time
where Healthcare is more difficult to
access this bill would even further harm
students by taking that care away as a
college student living in New Hampshire
full-time through throughout the year
health and wellness at UNH is the only
way I can access Affordable Health Care
along with many of my peers and
especially since both my parents are
small business owners my health
insurance is never really guaranteed I
visited the healthc Care Center on
campus for a variety of reasons
throughout my nearly three years here as
a student and each time has more than
exceeded expectations I trust that the
doctors and nurses who have cared for me
there gave me accurate and thorough
information including medications and
referrals
if HB 434 is passed the trust the
wellness center has established with
every student on campus would be
diminished diminished especially when it
comes to reproductive Health Care since
medical professionals would no longer be
able to relay every option available to
patients at no fault of their own but
rather at the fault of government
interference my peers and I deserve the
right to accurate and thorough health
care and this should not be impeded upon
by the views of certain politicians I
ask that you oppose house B 434 thank
Banis seeing none again thank you for
your
testimony just for the committee sake I
would ordinarily take a break right now
but we have just three other people who
have signed up and rather than take a
break now I just assume get those done
and then we can have a long lunch hour
if that's okay with
yes Mr chair thank you and thank you
Judiciary Committee members for taking
my testimony today I'm Walt Stapleton a
representative from Claremont ward 3
Sullivan County District 5 and I am in
support of both 434 and
596 the state has a reasonable valid and
lawful interest in protecting life and
the well-being of its citizens including
the pre-born as future functioning
citizens so it follows that the state
should not fund what is adverse to its
interests um the interests of the state
are clear in both the constitution of
the state in um article two natural
rights all men have certain natural
essential and inherent rights among
which are the enjoying and defending
life and Liberty and so forth and then
again in
RSA um
32941 at Roman 1 nothing in this
subdivision shall be construed as
creating or recognizing a right to
abortion Roman two it is not the
intention of this subdivision to make
lawful an abortion that is currently
unlawful a HB
596 um is especially interesting because
it Fosters adoption and adoption is a
good alternative to abortion and
coincides with the public interest the
state has in protecting and fostering
life several testimonies have referred
to the federal hide Amendment as already
covering the matter uh there for making
this these bills
unnecessary however with the change of
presidential
Administration the Biden Administration
has already signaled the end of the
Mexico City policy and indicated
overturn avoiding of the Hide Amendment
so that leaves it squarely in the realm
of the states for uh the protections of
taxpayer money uh against the use by
abortion and thank you that is that
concludes my
testimony thank you representative are
there any questions for representative
[Music]
stapon seeing none again thank thanks
for your testimony
O'Hara hello can you hear me we can
thank you um hello and thank you Mr
chair and the rest of the honorable
Judiciary Committee I'm representative D
soara from bnap District 9 representing
all of lonia and Belmont I am neutral to
the bills due to the fact I have not
fully read both bills but I wanted to
testify about my experience with an
unplanned pregnancy and the impact on my
life I grew up in a lower middle class
family with split parents my girlfriend
at the time I was 15 years of
age um sorry got
pregnant I lost where I was I'm sorry
um and allowed me oh sorry ending and
not to and chose not to end the life of
my daughter allowed me to become the
adult I am today at the age of
27 having my daughter is what pushed me
to get my GED and go on to college at 16
where I took on federal student loans to
pay for yes we struggled at some points
with financial issues but we work
through it my daughter was one of my
largest campaigned donors with her love
and support I am also a small business
owner and work as a business intax
consultant
having an unplanned child does not mean
your life is over it means it's just
beginning in a different way that you're
not expecting um thank you for your time
I do not have written testimony but I
can provide it if
requested Mr
O'Hara did any questions from Mr
oara seeing none again thank you for
your
Cen
hello can you hear me
yeah um good uh morning Representatives
um my name is Leia Cohen I'm a resident
of molten Boro um I was not planning on
testifying this morning um so I do not
have written testimony but I've been
listening to today's hearings all
morning and I am absolutely outraged as
a resident of New Hampshire abortion is
Health Care this is not an opinion it is
an indisputable fact the attempts to
restrict access to healthcare amidst a p
pandemic a widespread economic recession
in which immense numbers of your
constituents are losing their jobs and
therefore their employment sponsored
Healthcare are short-sighted at best and
immoral and cruel at worst and I
especially find the notion of a
convenience abortion offensive is the
removal of your appendix a convenience
operation are the antibiotics you take
for strep throat convenience medications
would intubations to treat covid-19 be a
convenience treatment therefore I
strongly urge the committee to vote
these bills in expedient to legislate
and instead redirect your focus into
making Health Care More accessible for
the vulnerable vulnerable people you
were elected to serve We Trust our
public officials to look out for our
best interests and ensure our access to
the highest possible quality of life
that's the true Granite State Advantage
please itl these bills thank you for
your time I would prefer not to take
questions if that is
okay thank you thank you for your
testimony
arso hello yes we can hear you hello hi
uh dear members of the House Judiciary
Committee um thank you for taking the
time to listen to My Testimony I
apologize I had commitments this morning
so I was not able to hear um all of the
previous testimony um my name is Dr
Christine arnow I am a pediatrician and
the vice president of the New Hampshire
Pediatric Society the state chapter of
the American Academy of Pediatrics which
represents 242 pediatricians in New
Hampshire my testimony is on behalf of
that
organization I am testifying today in
opposition to house bills 434 and 596
because I believe that affordable access
to emergency contraception and abortion
is a Cru crucial aspect of women's
healthare I would also like to state
that the following organizations oppose
both of these bills the New Hampshire
Medical Society the American Medical
Association the New Hampshire American
College of Obstetrics and
gynecologists the New Hampshire American
College of Physicians the New Hampshire
Academy of family physicians and the New
Hampshire Psychiatric
Society a national report report
conducted by the CDC national Center for
Health statistics showed that 55% of
male and female teens have sexual
intercourse by age
18 as a mother of two young daughters I
understand the temptation to hide from
these
statistics while we educate and Foster a
culture of responsible sexual behavior
we must offer options for these
women these bills seek to severely
restrict access to abortion and
emergency contraception which would have
a negative app impact on te
teenagers teen pregnancy and
childbearing bring substantial social
and economic costs on teen parents and
their
children pregnancy and birth are
significant contributors to high school
dropout rates among girls only about 50%
of teen mothers are able to earn a high
school diploma compared to approximately
90% of women who do not give birth
during
adolescence children born to teenage
mothers are more likely to have lower
school achievement and to drop out of
high school have more health problems be
incarcerated at some time during
adolescence give birth as a teenager and
face unemployment as young
adults teenage pregnant pregnancy
disproportionately impacts black
Hispanic and Native people and women
from lowincome
backgrounds teens in child welfare
systems are at higher risk of teen
pregnancy and birth than other
groups because women from lowincome
backgrounds are at higher risk for teen
pregnancy it is crucial to provide
affordable emergency contraception and
abortion
Services studies suggest that almost one
in Four Women will have had an abortion
by the age of
45 the height Amendment currently bans
the use of federal funds for abortion
coverage for individuals enrolled in
Medicaid which means that these
procedures must be paid for out of
pocket or via State funds for those
without private insurance taking away
State supports as this bill suggests
would mean that women with low income in
including teenagers would need to pay
out of pocket for abortions at an
average cost of over $500 this is Out Of
Reach for many
women emergency contraception is a
medication that can prevent pregnancy
when used in the days immediately
following unprotected
interourse according to the 2006 to20
National survey of family growth 11% of
all sexually active women and nearly one
in four sexually active women ages 20 to
24 reported ever using emergency
contraception about half of these women
reported using emergency contraception
because of fear of method failure and
half because they had unprotected sex it
is appalling to imagine that any young
woman would be in a position where she
could not access emergency contraception
to give an example a college sophmore
who was using a condom and the condom
broke would not have the option to
access emergency
contraception abortion and emergency
contraception are two necessary aspects
of women's reproductive Health that must
be available and affordable to all women
the decision to proceed with one of
these therapies should be between a
woman and her doctor and should not be
limited by the government I strongly
oppose these bills thank you for taking
the time to listen to My
Testimony thank you for your testimony
dror are there any
arel sing that again thank you for your
testimony here
today and we have representative uh the
last person who hasn't spoken uh is
Perez thank you for giving me the
opportunity to speak up I've been
listening to all the testimonies and it
hurts me to hear um is talking about our
bodies it's a victim of a sexual assault
that was done by my own father when I
heard someone say we can give this to
kids these kids in
adoption I I don't think and I don't
believe someone can tell me that I has
to keep a pregnancy when I know that I
was raped by my own father and then I
was raped by someone else in my
family how can someone told me that I
have has to keep that baby in my body
when I'm already being abused this is
abusing our right I have the right to
choose if I want to keep that baby or
not to be honest it's hard for me to
talk about it it happened many years ago
but I listen to all these guys talking
about our bodies like we don't have the
right to choose please please I'm I'm
asking you don't let this don't let this
happen to us it's it's a big thing I'm
asking you and not putting you it's so
hard to listen to guys talking about
us thank you for your testimony are
Perez seeing none thank you for your
testimony is there anyone else who have
one there is a hand up from Melissa May
who has already spoken once
um I will allow her to speak briefly
since she is the last speaker but she
will be the last speaker and then we'll
hearing and
thank Miss May you've already spoken
once do you have something else in
addition to add and if you are going to
could you limit your testimony to
whatever new information you have to
provide yes thank you um I did get a
little emotional speaking um because
this is such a hard topic but I am a
mother of five um I've given 28 years of
my life to being a mother and I think
even when we have difficult situations
you always will live with the regret
that there is a baby that you lost with
abortion um we talked about other
Solutions um I know for me starting off
with very low income it was Wick
Medicaid food stamps food pantries um
all the resources in the community to
give life and now I give back to the
community um the hide Amendment with
President Biden we're looking at that
being overturned and I just want want to
add in in my the reason why I raised my
hand was I had a question for somebody
but we are you know using very deceptive
language this is not a blob of tissue um
this is not just our body there is a
baby involved there is personhood there
is somebody else so I I mean I could go
on and on which I won't but I really
feel this is um murder and what we need
to do is educate girls and really help
them understand this and as they hit
Womanhood a lot of times they hit
post-traumatic stress disorder uh this
damages the mother daughter connection
as many mothers um and parents force
their daughters into abortion um
thinking it's for their best and those
Generations are just destroyed so there
is no future economic um future without
the Next Generation okay thank you for
letting me speak
today ml you
yeah uh thank you Mr chair I was
wondering if you could indulge me I just
had a followup question for uh attorney
Ian huitt um if if it's possible I might
be able to ask that thank you for your
May uh representative mlan has indicated
that he has a question which he would
like to ask Ian hu and so we'll call
upon Mr hwit if he's still available to
respond to the question
good morning yes I'm available to take
your question thank you Mr chair and and
thank you um attorney hwit for indulging
me your testimony is always very dense
so it sometimes takes a little time for
me to process so yeah you testified that
there really was no gag order in this
legislation and I just want you to
clarify for me then um uh if I look at
the bill 132 colon 47 when it talks
about the public facilities assets for
abortion prohibited and it when it says
that those facilities cannot be used for
the purpose of providing performing or
participating so I just I just wanted to
be clear as to what your argument was
with respect to that provision of the
bill well if your suggestion
representative is that participating
could be construed to Encompass
referrals and then that's therefore gag
order um or maybe some kind of
unconstitutional condition I I don't
think that any courts likely to construe
um the bill that way if this bill came
before a court because the word referral
is used in other context okay so you
know courts will assume that legislators
chose with care the words included in
the statute and since referral is used
in other places to refer to like the
verbal Act of referring for an abortion
I don't think participate is likely to
be given that a broad construction as
encompassing a a verbal referral that
would include some sort of physical
contribution to the actual Act of an
abortion thank you very
much thank you for
Mr with that I see no other hands and I
will close that
hearing our hearings on the two bills
House Bill
434 and House Bill 5
96 and we are scheduled to be back we
don't have anything scheduled until
we're scheduled to be back at 1:00 for
House Bill
233 and I would let you know that there
are currently 19 people pre-registered
to testify on
233 and is there any other business we
recess seeing none we'll see you at 1:00
much so
him
[Music]
points
hello hello this is representative
Horgan again so I've got the uh got the
one
oh hello I was unmuted but I think I'm
still in the 10d well let me check yeah
I'm still in the 10d I should be a
panelist
thanks
for
I have a question if anybody could
answer it
um I have a a dog who needs a medical
appointment this evening and I am
worried it's in lonia which is a long
drive for me does anybody ever leave
early and if so do you get put in prison
later
um just speaking as one member of the
committee that would be fine yeah okay
um sometimes people even um try to
participate in these meetings like uh on
the on the car although that could be
problem that can be problematic but yes
we're not voting on anything I need
today anyway as far as the best of my
knowledge okay I I normally don't like
to do such things but I have had a
terrible time getting my dog an
appointment and they had a cancellation
it yeah I have to I have to beg out at
three o'clock I've let uh representative
D Lorenzo know as as well as Mary Beth
Waltz because of the bill at three
o'clock I have to be
elsewhere
H my dog is ridiculous ly
no I'm not sure how much how qualified I
anyway well what hair you do have called
fine okay
everyone uh just following up on the uh
discussion that was just had they intend
the internet here in the lob at 4
o'clock today so we hope to be done by
four o'clock today I note that on our
last bill the 3:00 Bill there were only
four people who signed up uh or
pre-registered to speak two of which are
uh state
representatives so uh but I know that
there are some additional speakers we
were informed there might be some
additional speakers but we hope to uh
conclude our business today uh before
four
o'clock
and we uh and if you have to leave early
that's fine we're not intending to have
today they I'm going to call again call
this meeting of the house Judiciary
Committee to order our next bill
scheduled for hearing today is House
Bill 233 FN relative to the right of any
infant born alive to medically
appropriate and reasonable care and
treatment and I will call upon the
primary sponsor representative ulery to
address
the thank you Mr chairman I wish I was
we were all back in the lb I remember
sitting in uh judici year years ago a
few uh at any rate uh HB 233 is nothing
more than guaranteeing that a child who
is born alive regardless of the of the
circumstances actually gets treatment I
had previously sent out some counters to
arguments that a that never happens and
no there's no such thing as but in fact
this is a guarantee
in law that when a child is born they
are going to receive
care nothing more and certainly nothing
less if a
child
by the grace of God survives an
live in the literature that I sent out
to the committee
earlier there were descriptions of
children being left to wither and die
without any assistance I find that
nothing less than
fanticide this bill has nothing to do
with a woman's choice
to uh have an abortion that's should be
addressed separately but it does deal
with whether or not a child who
survives should be guaranteed the right
to
live and that's something I think we all
live simple bill you have any questions
be glad to answer them thank you very
much are there any questions for
representative
viery singan thank you for your
testimony today
co-sponsor of the bill was
representative
Stapleton representative Stapleton you
testify representative Stapleton with
us yes uh I am with you and I wish to
testify can you hear me okay we can
thank you thank you Mr chair and members
of the Judiciary
Committee I am here as a co-sponsor and
in support of the bill that's titled
born alive infant protection act
HB um
233 several States uh let me identify
myself I am a a representative from
Claremont ward 3 Sullivan County
District 5 Walter
stable several States recently removed
all abortion restrictions up to the time
of birth and tentatively even
Beyond New York Virginia Vermont maybe
some
others so if abortion goes wrong or is
incomplete and the fetus survives the
procedure then with these states somehow
its life is in Jeopardy outside the
womb hence the need for a viability Pro
PRP ion and this bill to afford Express
protection of that born emerging
life this bill is in the reasonable and
valid interest of the state to protect
the life of its
citizens matured unborn
pre-born regardless and so I am in
support of U this bill and ask that it
be uh ought to pass thank you thank you
are there any questions for
representative
States seeing none thank you for your
testimony today thank you Mr
chair I just note for the committee's
benefit uh that there were registering
in support 170 people on the bill
registering in opposition were
people the uh
me hello good afternoon thank you for
the opportunity to testify my name is Dr
Julia me I'm a medical doctor I'm an
OBGYN I live in Lebanon and I practice
in the state of New Hampshire I'm
233 excuse me House Bill 233 the
so-called born alive bill is disguised
as a means of abortion restriction it's
written with purposefully confusing
misleading and medically inaccurate
language this bill seeks to regulate a
non-occurrence and to criminalize
something that does not happen speaking
as a doctor all doctors and medical
providers have an obligation to provide
appropriate Medical Care based on
evidence and the standard of care to all
patients unfortunately this bill would
have real consequences for patients and
their families who find themselves in
difficult and tragic situations through
no fault of their
own families were forced to go through
what no one should have to very early
labor in the death of a previable infant
meaning a baby who is born before it is
able to survive survive outside the
womb I have unfortunately seen these
situations many times in my job most
recently I'll tell you all about a story
a patient that I'll call
Holly um Holly had already had several
miscarriages in the early second
trimester babies who are born too early
to survive she came in and she very
strongly wanted to be a mom she um was
really eager to start her family with
her
partner she was about 18 weeks along
which is about 4 and a half months
pregnant um in the early second
trimester and she went into early labor
unfortunately she was admitted to the
hospital and we performed a procedure
meant to keep her pregnant longer we
actually sewed the opening to her uterus
closed with a stitch it's called a
cirage and it's meant to prolong her
pregnancy and allow her baby a longer
time to grow inside the uterus
unfortunately her water broke a few days
later and she um went into labor and
delivered her daughter shortly
afterwards at this tational age there
are no medical interventions that could
have saved her daughter or prolonged her
life performing procedures such as
inserting breathing tubes and IVs would
have kept Holly from spending whatever
moments she had with her daughter the
so-called born alive Bill ignores
medical realities it fails to
acknowledge the real life experiences of
families who are facing unimaginable
loss this bill would force medical
intervention even when doing so would be
fule it forces families to have to un
have to undergo brutal invasive
resuscitations and interventions instead
of holding their babies for their last
few hours of Life Healthcare decision
should be made by women in consultation
with their loved ones and doctors
including Specialists like Obstetricians
and neonatologists who are specialized
pediatricians dealing with very early
babies not by politicians or legislators
for these reasons I urge you to please
oppose House Bill 233 thank
you thank you are there any questions
for Dr
me okay representative
oper so Dr me you say that the
interventions were will
beutal and the baby couldn't
survive not quite understanding how this
bill would actually Supply in that
situation I wouldn't think that it would
I mean the child is born but if it
then you uh help me out that
yeah yeah that's exactly right um there
are babies that are born that in which
there's there's no um chance of survival
and um there is no reason to perform
interventions on these babies um it
really only seeks to to harm harm them
in their final moments of life and and
also it's I think it's harmful to
families to have to see that when really
most people would want to hold their
baby
more yes could follow up so
care you don't think that care is
appropriate how is it required by the
bill
me
well
um yeah I think this bill would offer
the opportunity for women to have a
choice whether they would want
representative
Alexander um thank you Mr chair and
thank you doctor for taking my question
um my question comes from um your
statement about how the bill has
medically inaccurate language I guess
I'm kind of looking at section two it
says born alive the actual language um
is the complete expulsion or extraction
for the mother of human infant at any
stage of development who after expulsion
or extraction breathes has a beating
heart or has a definite movement of
voluntary
muscles what is inaccurate about that or
or what what else needs to be included
accurate um I think that there are uh
situations in in babies's Born right at
the cusp of
viability um meaning right around the
age when when maybe some babies would
survive certainly some other babies
would not and I think had it
um I don't think that everyone should be
forced to undergo resuscitation of a
viability Mr chair just to followup if I
could um I'm wondering doctor what
additional language would need to be
included that would help specify what
the cusp of viability is in which um
recess or or um preserving the life
you yeah I think that this is um a
difficult question we don't have a
medical definition um every situation is
different and that's why I think that
experts should um make a decision about
what there is no defined age of
viability um thus it doesn't need to be
Bill you're the expert that's why I was
asking you thank
questions see that thank you again Dr
me and the next person to uh actually
yeah the next person to testify is
Christopher
available
is
unmute I'm sorry technical problems can
you hear me now hear you now yeah thank
you very much Mr chairman and the
committee for this opportunity for to
testify I'm a
neonatologist and I live in Handover and
practice in New Hampshire uh and uh I
like to me uh the reasons why I uh would
object to this bill are are sort of
twofold I I I think like the prior
speaker there are many instances where
babies are born and are living but
they're uh they they do are not able to
survive so I think this bill uh in in my
estimation the warning about uh
appropriate Medical Care and the other
warning is inherently ambiguous and I
worry about while I understand the
sentiment behind it I worry about the
intent to legislate what really is a
personal
decision on the part of the parents and
their caregivers around what is uh the
appropriate thing to offer for a baby in
this
condition some of these uh infants are
as previously noted uh extremely mature
infants at the edge of viability but uh
this uh bill would
also I think uh unreasonably Encompass
infants who have uh who are born later
in gestation but have uh conditions that
are uniformly fatal early in life and
for whom uh instituting medical support
has no hope of helping them ultimately
and only um causes them to experience
pain or
discomfort so I think
basically uh
the the attempt to legislate what really
incorrect thank you are are there any
Dr seeing none thank you for your
testimony today okay thank you very
today if you're there please raise your
you
next person is Dr Maris
[Music]
Tolen hi can you hear me we can hi my
name is Dr Maris toand I'm a resident
physician In Obstetrics and Gynecology
at Dartmouth Hitchcock um I live in uh
Lebanon New Hampshire I practice in New
Hampshire I'm speaking on behalf of
myself I'd like to add to the testimony
of Dr to say that I oppose House Bill
233 based on the fact that I think it's
unnecessary misleading and is unable to
adequately address ambiguity in a
particularly challenging um period of
time in infants lives I I don't think
this bill has anything to do with how
abortion care actually works and is
based on these false claims and similar
to what Dr me and Dr Ringer have
mentioned I do believe this bill has
clear consequences for um previable and
potentially later term infants who are
born with conditions that do not make
them able to
survive um every situation is different
um but similar to to the other doctor's
testimony there are situations in which
um we cannot save the life of a fetus
and I I would just like to reiterate how
painful and um heart-wrenching it is to
take care of these families these
desperate situations when an infant has
a medical condition that is futile and
not able to be salvaged um passage of
this bill could potentially mean that
those infants with only a few moments or
hours or even days to live and no hope
of meaningful life would be taken out of
the arms of their parents and forced to
go through painful unnecessary and
feudal medical procedures that would
only prolong
suffering um if you've ever witnessed a
loved one perhaps a beloved parent or a
grandparent who has undergone CPR or
aggressive medical interventions at the
end of their life you know that this can
be traumatizing and painful um the
entire field of hospice care originated
from a desire to provide compassionate
end of life care to those with terminal
diagnosis um while people don't often
think that that may happen to to infants
it can um when I took an oath to become
a doctor I swore that I would do no harm
to my patients and I worry that this
bill could um could encourage the
possibility that providers would feel
it's necessary to inflict suffering on
infants that are born without a hope for
survival because of the threat of
criminalization I do feel that um this
bill reveals the consistent strategy of
anti-abortion politicians whose ultimate
goal is to ban all abortions um without
consideration of that ambiguity um and
and without without uh the grayness that
sometimes comes with these periods of
time um in medical
situations from a medical perspective um
I don't think that this is something
that should be placed in the legislature
but rather left up to medical
professionals ethics committees and
parents to uh to make decisions about
what's best for their family um I would
respectfully urge this committee to
oppose House Bill 233 thank you very
much I submitted this um testimony in
writing and uh representative silver do
you have a question yes I do have a
question thank you doctor for taking my
question uh I'm wondering if you can
tell me if abortions uh at Dartmouth hit
shot facilities are being done uh on uh
fetuses that have gational ages of 24
older uh I I believe that you asked me
this question yesterday repres
representative silur and and I'm sorry
that I um that I was not able to answer
it uh to your satisfaction yesterday um
this is not something that I personally
have seen and um and I I cannot give you
a straight strict answer um I have not I
have not seen it personally thank
you are there any other questions for Dr
to seeing none thank you for your
testimony again today
thank
you uh the next speaker will be Jason
Hennessy and then after Mr Hennessy I'll
duckar thank you Mr chairman uh house
Judiciary Committee honorable
members um I'd like to point out that in
this in this bill and in this debate
there's no debate about the humanity of
these children um these are children who
have taken a breath who who have have
completely separated from their mothers
um and I and I'd like to suggest that
this is there's no greatness in this
area like was suggested by the previous
speaker um I'd like to read to you
article a portion of article two of the
New Hampshire
Constitution and it
states um that all men have certain
natural essential and inherent rights
among which are the enjoying and
defending life and
Liberty and so I'd like to I'd like to
submit to you that as the as the
representatives of the people um who
represent our government this is table
Stakes for you um defending defending
the the life and Liberty of those who
are born is is just is is the is the
basic essence of what your job is and
I'm I'm actually sad to have to speak on
this bill um because I'm sad that these
protections aren't there already
um one thing I'd like to point out is
that the interests of those in in the
room um if a if a child is born this way
may not align with the interests of the
child one of those parties is was paid
to to end its
life um and and those part and and those
parties are the ones that are testifying
to you to say that this isn't a problem
um I think there's a there's a
compelling State interest here and and
if the uh taking care of the child is is
a concern Hampshire has Safe Haven laws
that allow the mother to relinquish um
uh responsibilities for their child to
the
state in terms of whether this can
happen it does there's evidence of this
um gnell kerm goell who was an an
abortion provider in in in Philadelphia
was convicted of snapping the necks of
of a couple of different babies who were
born this way according to the loer
Institute which was quoting from public
records of the CDC in Florida uh 11
babies were born alive from an abortion
in 2017 in Florida and they also found
that there were at least 143 babies who
died after
abortions um this is based on CDC data
between 200 2003 2014 and the CDC
data says itself that it underestimates
it so uh with that I would love to take
any questions thank
you yes representative
Oregon thank you very much Mr chair and
thank you much Mr Hennessy um I just
using expression that wasn't really
familiar with which was called table
stakes and um far as know that is
something that's the term from like
poker and I'm not sure exactly so what
what does it mean in this context and U
how in might also address why a poker
game is analogous to the decision of H
what to do when you oh sure excellent
excellent question sorry that's not
viable I I didn't realize I was using uh
jargon yeah t so in my in my mind table
Stakes is basically this is this is the
basics of what you do um you know it's
hard to it's hard to think of ourselves
as being a free society that um ensures
the natural right to life if we don't if
we don't protect babies who are
completely
defenseless okay thanks any any other
questions
Mr
Hennessy see thank you for your
testimony today thank
you next speaker would be Dr Melissa
duckberry
can you hear me okay we can hear you hi
um hello my name is Dr Melissa Duxbury
um I am what one might refer to as the
gray hair in the building I am a family
medic medicine physician that has been
in New Hampshire for almost 20 years uh
I was pre I work in the Southern Tier as
uh previously the immediate P president
of the New Hampshire uh Academy of
family medicine and I would like to
thank you for allowing me to do
testimony today and I hope that you're
all feeling and doing well if covid has
taught me anything in uh this year and
almost a half a million deaths it has
reminded me that sometimes no matter how
hard we try no matter what we do we
cannot save everyone and that sometimes
in the process of trying to save someone
we can strip them of their dignity and
their Humanity the bill this bill House
Bill 233 strips the Dignity of the
family and the mother and the physician
and the family and people taking care of
them New Hampshire can do better I have
lived here for most of my life and
firmly believe that we have done a good
job in trying not to get between
patients and
Physicians this removes the decision of
the family when there's a pregnancy
where we know the child will not survive
instead of having time to hold the
infant process the grief we'll be
ripping that child from the hands of the
family to do invasive painful fruitless
procedures because someone and in all
respect to all of you who has never had
to intubate do CPR resuscitate an infant
is telling us what we have to do it
removes the right of the parents and the
physician to do what's right for the
family and the patient providers know
how to take care of patients legislation
is not intended to come between you and
your doctor but it
can would we remove the right of a
patient dying of terminal cancer not to
be resuscitated I'm sure everyone here
has had a family member who has had
terminal cancer or something we know we
can no longer cure or
treat do we trust that doctor and the
family and the patient to know what's
best for the patient or do we legislate
that they must continue to resuscitate
do we ask a physician to break every
every rib shove a tube down the throat
of your parents or your grandparents
who've asked for the dignity to die
naturally this is no different it's not
often that Physicians agree I firmly say
that you can't get more than two doctors
to order pizza and that's only because
half and half and anybody who's ever
gone to a specialist and then another
specialist and then another specialist
will tell you we never agree on anything
however here are the following medical
societies who feel that this bill in its
form form is a bad idea that it is not
doing what is right for the patient and
anyone who's ever known me will know
that I stand up always for the patient
the New Hampshire Medical Society the
American Medical Society the new
manshire American College of
obstetrician and gynecologists the New
Hampshire Academy of family physicians
that's who I'm a member of and
representating the New Hampshire Academy
of Pediatrics the New Hampshire College
of Physicians the new sure Psychiatric
Society I put to you that that is
thousands of Physicians who can't ever
agree on ordering pizza at lunch when we
used to have to do it for covid prior to
that that should mean something to you
that should tell you something this body
has already rejected the previous Bill
last year HB 1675 only a year ago
because it's dangerous and misleading it
has real life consequences and I put to
you that the reason so many of these
Physicians and and I I appreciate Mr
Hennessy's testimony but I have had to
be there with a mother who's lost her
child who has creedu shot or tricomi 18
who will live for a half an hour or an
hour but will live no longer who
surfactant in their lung is not allowing
them to Breathe No Matter What tube we
put them
in the last time I did that was 21 years
ago and I remember it to the
day it means something when your
provider and you have the right to
decide what is right for you and your
family
I don't think this bill is good for New
Hampshire I don't think this bill is
good for patients I don't think this
bill is good for parents and and and
although Mr Hennessy states that
everyone here that there who's
testifying I have never once in my life
performed that procedure but I know what
right for my patients I know this bill
is not right for my patients and I urge
you to reconsider or to think hard about
this bill and think not just about that
baby but about what that means later on
for your families and your parents and
their rights to
choose Thank you thank you are there any
saying none thank you for your testimony
today thank
you I don't see her on the attendees
list but Patrice Meyers signed up to
speak if you're out there please raise
your
hand
don't
Young Dr Young raise your hand if you're
out
there that unmute came up a little late
um Dr you're on all right thank you uh
very much for the opportunity to speak
in opposition to HB
233 as I said yesterday I'm o young a
retired obstetrician
gynecologist who practiced in conquered
for over 35 years I'm a past president
of New Hampshire Medical Society and
presently remain on the general Council
representing uh
Obstetricians of our state I'm also a
clinical
Adjunct professor at the G school of
medicine at Dartmouth having taught
students for almost 40
years uh I want to confirm that those
uh organizations which we just heard uh
oppose this bill are in fact true I was
going to say that I'm representing the
Hampshire uh chapter of the American
College of OB Joan as well as the New
Hampshire Academy of Pediatricians New
Hampshire College of Physicians New
Hampshire Society of Psychiatry New
Hampshire Academy of family physicians
uh and the
AMA as well as the New Hampshire Medical
Society it is with
disbelief that many of us have read and
R this bill HB 233 as I read it suggests
that Physicians do not always provide
appropriate care for a baby and in
particular aive viable
baby that is just
untrue and frankly it's
offensive this legislation is an effort
or is an affront to all of us who care
for pregnant women and their babies we
do not need a state law to assure that
New Hampshire doctors render care to a
live viable newborn in every
case this bill perpetuates the false
notion that there are late term
abortions in New Hampshire provided for
women and healthy babies please
understand that the only late
terminations of pregnancies in New
Hampshire are performed when babies have
have severe congenital anomalies
incompatible with life live babies with
congenital Anon anomalies incompatible
with life belong in their parents'
arms not in a neonatal Intensive Care
Unit this law would have us treating
these babies with interventions that
prolong their lives and suffering and
even worse separating from their
grieving parents
this legislation does not distinguish
between a live
birth with previable gestational age
from a live birth mature enough to
survive some pregnancies as you've heard
deliver before viability because of
premature labor premature ruptured
membranes the breaking of
water an early separation of the
placenta or a cervix that's
insufficient the mouth of the womb
dilating early in
pregnancy all of
these
complications are
unavoidable they're not known to The
Physician or the patient before they
occur I have been there many
times after the birth of a premature
baby thin
skinned eyelids
fused frequent small gasp yes it's
alive but unable to expand its lungs he
Dr Young if you could finish up
apprciate it is a heartbreaking moment
for the couple and the physician helpl
us to save this baby healing only occurs
by placing the baby on the mom's
chest and letting her have a few hours
of this Baby's short life
okay on rare
occasion life maternal complications are
associated with pregnancy I had a
patient Dr Young I'm asking you if you
would just finish up please we okay I
just want to
finish I have always held chairman
Gordon that there's a sacred contract
between Physicians and Society we
sacrifice a good part of our youth and
early adulthood for training and devote
the rest of our lives to care for our
fellow men for that all we ask is a
reasonable environment in which to
practice and HB
233 violates that contract the practice
of medicine thank you do of private
intimate moments of medical care that
must be left to the patient and the care
provider
Young yes representative mcth thank you
uh Mr chairman and thank you Dr Young
for taking my example my question could
could you remind us again where you
practiced
ask you need to unmute Dr Young I
practiced at conquered Oban in conquered
New Hampshire for over 35
years thank you have any other questions
Young sing thank you for your testimony
today uh I noticed that uh
representative Schmidt signed up to
testify but I don't see representative
attendees and if you are out there
hand the next person is Mary Ellen
Carter
hand
Jean
rusa thank you Mr chair and members of
the committee my name is Jeanie hesa and
I'm the political director for the
American civil liberties Union of New
Hampshire and I really appreciate the
opportunity to testify today in
opposition to HB
233 as the sponsors of this bill noted
this bill is not about
abortion this bill is about an impacts
end of life
care I don't think I'm the only one I'm
guessing I'm not the only one um in this
virtual room who has been in the very
difficult situation of watching a loved
one survive on life support
their life is being
preserved but at what cost I know
speaking for myself I watched a loved
one wither away on life support wishing
every single day that I could take him
off of it but I didn't have that
power anyone who has had to make that
impossible
decision of when to take a loved one off
life support knows how excruciating
those decisions are and knows how there
is no one-sized fits-all decision for
all end of life
scenarios this bill is about these
impossible decisions where an infant has
only hours or days to live and a family
must decide how to spend the little time
they have left with their
child HB 233 would deny parents the
ability to choose the type of
Compassionate Care that works for their
family and their faith in these
situations as we would allow them to do
at any other point in their child's life
if a child were dying at the age of one
five or even six months we would
entirely trust the parents in
consultation with their doctor to make
the best decision regarding
Compassionate Care for their
child I don't think I'm wrong to say
that no politician would dare insert
their own judgment into that situation
and yet this bill says parents and
doctors cannot be trusted in just such
an endof life decision merely because of
when the tragedy is
happening there may be medical
procedures that could quote preserve the
life of an infant but for how long
preserve it for five minutes for an
hour to at what cost at how much pain to
that infant to the family if this bill
becomes law Dr would be forced to
deviate from their best medical judgment
and administer painful treatments to
infants knowing that the infants don't
have the chance at
survival and put in treatment that would
be against the wishes of the
parents rather than relying on their
training and expertise to care for a
dying infant doctors would have to take
direction from politicians to avoid
criminal
liability this bill removes all
decision-making power from parents and
instead forces doctors to subject a
dying infant to futile medical
procedures these end of life decisions
are hard they're hard if the person is
at the end of their long and beautiful
life and these decisions are hard for a
baby who's been in this world for two
minutes but legislation like this does
not help we should trust doctors and
Trust amilies and allow families to make
these decisions according to their faith
and what works best for their
families I will submit my written
testimony uh but for these reasons the
ACLU respectfully urges members of this
committee to vote itl on HB
233 thank you for your testimony are
there any
rusa see none again thank thank you for
your testimony
today next call upon Amy Kaufman if she
is
available again if you are out there you
might want to raise your hand so we
could identify you if you're under a
different
name
we
Kayla
Montgomery hi uh good afternoon
honorable chairman members of the House
Judiciary Committee my name is Kayla
Montgomery I'm the director of public
affairs for plan parent in New Hampshire
action fund plan parent from Northern
New England and we oppose House Bill 233
and I have submitted written testimony
um so I want to do this in two parts
today I want to talk first about why
this bill is wrong and then I want to
talk about some of the unintended
consequences of this bill um so to begin
the the title and the concept of this
bill is clearly intended to be
inflammatory it implies and the sponsors
also implied that doctors are committing
infanticide to be clear this is illegal
it is not happening in New Hampshire and
as already noted it is extremely
offensive to healthc Care Professionals
who work to help people every single day
and regardless of some things that you
might have heard today infants born are
currently protected under New
Hampshire's criminal statutes that is a
fact doctors are obligated to provide
appropriate Medical Care and to suggest
otherwise is false offensive and
dangerous um someone previously Mr
Hennessy brought up the Kermit gnell
case I just I wanted to flag that gnell
uh is a murderer he is in jail for life
for
and we all agree with
that so um I want to talk a little bit
about the the extreme consequences of
this bill and whether they're intended
or not this is what this bill actually
does so as we've gone over a few times
every pregnancy and every situation is
unique but this is a bill about early
labor and not about abortion so we're
talking about this point in pregnancy
which is generally towards the end of
the second trimester we're talking about
these much-wanted pregnancies when
families are desperate to leave the
hospital with a
newborn doctors involved in these cases
are working to save lives both of the
pregnant person and of the
infant so this is this incredibly
unfortunate space where families are
faced with these complicated and tragic
decisions regarding to these pregnancy
complications or early labor or a fatal
fetal diagnosis
when a pregnant person has a serious
health complication that puts her life
in risk or she goes into early labor the
standard of care is always to care for
the pregnant person and the infant we
have heard
this additionally there are some
complicated circumstances where an
infant might be born prematurely or have
health issues that are so severe for
example a lack of a brain or a lack of
lungs that sometimes in these extreme
cases the most approp riate Medical Care
is comfort care and involved in the
situation always our Advanced Medical
Teams some of whom we've heard from
today who have several different
Specialties including neonatal
Specialists the real danger of this bill
is that it restricts and it dictates the
standard of care in these incredibly
complicated circumstances and it
interferes with the doctor's ability to
provide the most appropriate care for
the family and it does so under the
threat of Crim criminal
penalties so the passage of this bill
could dictate how parents get to spend
the last few days or hours with their
babies before they pass this bill
grieve I will conclude but just by
saying that
um I encourage this community to think
about the families in these
heartbreaking
situations and please don't take the
worst possible day of a parent's life
and make it even worse by requiring
treatments that simply can't work just
yesterday in this committee we heard a
very tragic story okay um in some this
bill is not needed in New Hampshire and
I thank you for your time we urge you to
itl this uh uh House Bill 233 thank you
Montgomery seeing none thank you for
your testimony today thank
you that actually completes the list of
those who pre-registered to testify and
see that we do have some hands up from
people who wish to
Conley yes thank you for letting me
testify um my name is Dr David Conway
I'm a board certified OBGYN uh I'm
currently president of the New Hampshire
Board of Medicine but I'm not testifying
for the board I'm testifying testifying
for myself I don't have a lot to add to
all of the opinions you've had uh from
the various uh uh people opposing this I
did want to make some
statements uh concerning Mr Hennessy's
test testimony he takes a very broad
brush in describing abortion and I don't
think this this bill should be about
abortion um and in my training I was
um present for the bir of uh induced
abortions at 18 weeks where babies came
out they gasped they had a heartbeat and
they were clearly not candidates for
resuscitation they were candidates for
Humane care uh for a good part of my
career I practiced in rural uh
Pennsylvania and attended uh several
births of premature infants um one set
of twins at 24 weeks where where we were
2 and a half hours from the nearest
neonatal ICU and were able to deliver
them and stabilize them and one of them
survived but it is a real challenge when
you start taking care of babies um who
are really approaching the limits of
survivability I really don't have
anything more than that to say I I
sincerely oppose this bill and for all
of the reasons people have stated thank
you very much thank you for your
Conway seeing none again thank thank you
for testifying today I also see state
testify thank you um Mr chair Gardon for
giving me the
opportunity um testifying opposition of
this bill um and again this is a really
really hard for me to uh tell tell
everyone my story but um my sister
passed away when she was 23 years
old she was um another vicin on my my
dad um and then she was raped when she
was
little but she didn't take it the same
way I did um she
got she started using drugs when she was
14 years
old um she was raped Again by someone on
the streets she got
HIV my sister got
HIV and when she got
prant um both of the she had twins and
she passed away and she had these babies
and both of the babies that were born
I'm listening to all these guys talking
about woman's
bodies I wish my sister was here and I
wish I can have my niece and my nephew
here with me but my sister she she went
back to Salvador and she had the kids in
Old Salvador and according to the
immigration lot even that I'm a US
citizens but because of my niece and
nephew they have hi the not allowed to
come I wish I can do an adoption and
have them here and support them anyway
it's possible but I cannot so I'm I'm
and I'm asking you please do not pass
this law we we can't do this to victim
like my sister I wish my sister was here
with me and I wish my my niece and my
nephew didn't have HIV and then it's
more hospital bills and medication that
they has to take for the rest of the
life life thank you thank you are there
any questions for representative
Perez seeing none again thank you for
your testimony
testify yes sir thank you thank you very
much chairman Gordon for allowing me to
speak uh my name is the Reverend Dr
Emily Heath I'm the senior pastor of the
Congregational Church in exer we're a
member of the United Church of Christ
I'm speaking today in opposition to Bill
233 uh I don't want to talk about
abortion care today I want to talk about
the real consequences of this bill for
families in my church and my community
I'm not a physician I'm just a pastor uh
but I have been a hospital chaplain
including at a children's hospital
hospital and as a Hospice chaplain that
means unfortunately I've been with a
number of families while their loved
ones died and this has unfortunately
included newborn
babies like people of all ages uh some
babies are not going to survive their
diagnosis and viability is not an
option I've uh been with a lot of loving
parents who have had to make hard
decisions about whether to resuscitate
or whether to take Extraordinary
Measures it's so hard to make these
calls I've sat with these families as
their chaplain and as their
pastor and I've watched parents who know
that their children will not survive
more than a few hours or days talk about
how they don't want to cause their child
more pain instead they they want time to
hold the child they want time to be with
the child to uh impart the love of that
family with the
child they often want their clergy
member um their Pastor or their pri
Prest to baptize a child something that
for those of us who are clergy who
believe in infant baptism must be done
while the child is
alive um if the child is is undergoing
medical care that is not going to save
their life but just Pro
prolong um prolong a life that will not
be be saved ultimately then it's
actually taking away their right to have
the child receive this religious
sacrament by saying you you can't
baptize this kid we have to go and do
this uh medical procedure on them it's
eating into precious time for the family
and the family's community and it's
heartless to put parents in that
position it's heartless to not give them
the time to let the child meet them
their siblings their grandparents their
religious
community and medical staff shouldn't
have to be concerned about the
ramifications and even criminalization
of making the best informed choice that
their training and ethics provides for
them this is just going to hurt grieving
families by taking away dignity and
comfort and increasing the trauma that
they will doubtlessly already have and
so I ask you uh having been there for so
many of these precious last moments of a
newborn please don't politicize this
please please leave this up to families
and their medical staff thank you so
much thank you for your testim
are there any questions the
Reverend seeing none thank thank you
testify find her she was up and then she
went
she
hi hi Miss scar can you hear
us yes can you hear me
can go go ahead and test okay hi yeah my
name is Beth scare I live in nashwa and
um I just wanted to point out that most
all the people opposing the bill um
totally missed the point of the bill uh
reading from it it says any born alive
in infant including one born in the
course of abortion she'll be treated as
a legal person and under the laws of the
state with the same rights to medically
appropriate and reasonable care and
treatment any health care provider
present at the time the infant is born
shall take all all medically appropriate
and reasonable actions to preserve the
life and health of the born alive infant
so everyone who is opining about how
this would require
extraordinary
interventions or prevent the baby from
being baptized or put on a ventilator
when the baby's near death is just a
total misinterpretation of the law and
I'm really shocked especially at jeie
rusa who uh should know better than uh
to misinterpret the plain language of
this law and um also I wanted to point
out um there is no restriction on
abortion you know it's it's it's legal
through all nine months of pregnancy in
New Hampshire and there's no there's no
accounting done so we have no idea how
late abortions are being performed
although today we heard that they are
performing third trimester abortions
from one of the
doctors and we don't know who's
surviving we don't know what condition
they're they're survive what condition
they're being born in after abortions
and um Jason pointed out in other states
they are keeping track of this and we
know it's
happening and um Melissa Odin is an
abortion Survivor she wrote a book um
you carried me where she recounts how
her own mother was
uh forced to undergo an abortion as a
teenager and um while her grandm her
grandmother forced the abortion on her
own daughter and while her grandmother
was out of the room and Melissa's mom
was unconscious Melissa was born alive
after the failed
abortion and by the grace of God a nurse
took pity on her and got her medical
care and the question is if the family
were given the choice of whether to
provide medical care would that
grandmother who forced that abortion
allowed Medical Care to be
performed I'm guessing she wouldn't have
so I mean these are the situations that
babies are being born
into and I I'm asking you to vote OTP on
HB 233 so that these born Alive babies
can be
treated like any other human being in
the state and be provided appropriate
Medical Care thank you thank you for
your
testimony and there's a question from
representative MC
Beth thank you um chair Gordon it's not
a question it's a clarification from the
chair I'm just curious as a new member
of the committee do do we um allow
witnesses to project um you know
motivations on other people that have um
submitt a testimony or testified before
us on this bill as well as
um well I'll leave it there thank you no
we do not ordinarily do that and I
understand that it's happened a couple
of times today I've tried
not not to intervene and let make it
more of an issue than it has to be in
certain cases but no you're absolutely
correct we don't uh encourage people to
direct their comments towards other
chair any any questions you have for
Miss
scare seeing none thank you for your
testimony
again and there's someone the name is f
tar
F oh that's
me we can hear you okay good actually my
name is Amy Kaufman and thank you and
thank you the committee for hearing me
I'm from
newfields and I appreciate the
opportunity to testify today in
opposition to HB
233 I'm a single mother of two girls and
should anything happened to either of my
daughters it would be on me to decide
their end of life care I personally
would not be able to see either of my
children hooked up to life support um
equipment and knowing that they had no
future to live on their
own such difficult decisions about our
loved ones are
personal and I know this because my mom
just died so as my children's medical
proxy um it's a difficult
decision but I shudder at the notion of
politicians telling me what would be
best for my children most of us would
never think it appropriate to intrude on
such private moments yet that's what HB
233 is doing the bill protects no one it
would only serve to create pain and
suffering by denying families the right
to make their own
compassionate very emotional decisions
about their infant and consultation with
their doctor and in accordance to their
own faith for these reasons I
respectfully urg members of this
committee to vote in opposition to HB
233 and thank you very much thank you
questions seeing none thank you for your
sorry we have uh representative ulery
ulery there we go got the button up
there thank you very much Mr chair for
the opportunity to speak again uh you've
heard some testimony uh in this
presentation thus far some of which I
was kind of shocked to hear uh one of
the Physicians actually is my wife's uh
PCP which shocked me to know in because
the expression that she had uh that that
doctor had given um in
conversations was
more uh generalized than
the presentation that was given to the
committee was very very shocking I just
wanted the committee to be aware of
that okay as was St as was stated in
this by others in this bill there is an
escape clause and a lot of the testimony
ignored that within the bill is language
that says medically
appropriate and a lot of the people
testifying seem to have glossed over
that
and talked about the worst case
scenarios which is something we as
legislators need to be aware of but
within this bill is the Clause that says
medically appropriate for the
circumstances then in there
existing that is the important thing to
remember about this
bill and I thank the the chair for the
opportunity to speak again and I thank
the committee for listening to this
sometimes emotional testimony on by the
way I've delivered babies in the field
I've delivered dead babies in the field
I've resuscitated babies in the field uh
when I was a paramedic okay thank you
and represent Horgan did you have a
question more in the nature of a point
of order which was uh the representative
just spoke
revealed the name of his wife's uh
primary care position that seems like a
breach of his wife's poverty privacy I
don't really know whether or not she
really I just said an individual I
didn't say which which one of the
several doctors that spoke all
right
thanks I don't think he named the doctor
he pointed out what he thought was an
doctors representative Chase did you
have a
question Mr chair um thanks for taking
my question what exactly who decides
what is medically appropriate and could
you Define that for me please the
medical the medical determines what's
medically appropriate the bill doesn't
the bill doesn't say in every instance
it says what's medically appropriate
it's the same decision I had to make
several times is a paramedic whether the
continue res resuscitation of an adult
or a child or an infant or whether not
to continue res
resuscitation in the field the doctor in
the hospital said or in a in a clinic
setting who makes the decision whether
or not it's appropriate to continue or
to do extraordinary um Services that's
the medical decision of the medical
questions seeing none thank you for your
M May are you there she's there you have
to unmute I think can you hear me you
can hear you
now okay good great okay so here I am
testifying again um I testified
yesterday say about freedom of speech um
today the destruction of
abortion I am for this bill HB
233 um we definitely need oversight in
the medical field we the people are in
charge of the
Constitution there is um the 14th
amendment that protects the privacy of
women but it is balanced with the
viability of a baby and that's at nine
weeks we hear a heartbeat as far as
medically appropriate 34 years ago I was
at OBGYN in
conquered I had no counsel no informed
consent I was brought in I was quickly
taken I was taken upstairs who knew what
was happening I had something being put
into me now I know they were rods
dilating me but at the time I did not
know I was told to leave I left with
somebody was taken to a
restaurant lunch was ordered I could not
sit up I could not move I was in so much
pain no medication I was killed over a
waitress at week's restaurant had said
are is she okay is she going to be okay
the person covered said we'll take the
bill let's get out of here she said to
me we went into the car I was in labor
in a car no medical care I was in agony
somehow I made it back I zoned out went
upstairs saw the vacuum with the blood
coming out the nurse stood in front of
me so she could block that blood scene I
was seeing stared at the wall she took
my hand and said it's going to be
okay I was then taken back to my home by
somebody only to walk down the road
first so nobody would know what would
happen in gym class the next day in
school this is not medically appropriate
care there was a throwing me on the pill
afterwards no
counsel there was no healing and Miss
May this is just chairman Gordon I just
like you to address the the bill if you
could okay yes I'm sorry I'm sorry the
bill I definitely support for over
oversight um for the medical community
we are all held accountable to one
another um and we definitely have that
right to ask our rep representatives to
balance this out with the um with the
baby the baby has a right to live and we
should be doing everything we can to
save a baby I mean it's just human
nature and our society has always prided
itself in caring for the poor the
widowed the fatherless and this adds to
a culture of death when we want a
culture of life and that's my testimony
thank you thank thank you for your
testimony today are there any questions
from his
man seeing that again thank thank you
for your testimony yep and we have a
testify
hello again hello members of the New
Hampshire State Judiciary my my name is
Kate Maloney and I am the New England
regional coordinator for students for
life of
America and I am here today to represent
the pro-life interest for pro-life
students in the New Hampshire area and I
am testifying to support House Bill
233 the merits of this bill are
straightforward to provide protection
Aid and medical treatment to infants who
are born alive where I think this bill
is receiving significant backlash is
that this bill recognizes that abortion
procedures can fail the only way to have
a successful abortion procedure is if
the pre-born human in the womb is
terminated when they're not you have an
infant who is in fact born alive there
are countless stories Rosa Rodriguez a
young woman in New York Melissa Odin
Gianna jessen CLA cwell and a student I
know personally who are abortion
survivors they were born in an abortion
facility and due to the born alive
infant protection laws in that state at
those certain times or by the actions of
someone else they were saved they were
rushed on had emergency medical
treatment because they were recognized
under the law as persons who were
deserving of medical treatment so this
bill recognizes that the fact that the
primary role of a health care physician
is to do no harm and to save as much
life as
possible many of the doctors and medical
professionals commenting on this bill
today spoke of how this bill violates
the way in which they can care for their
patients I do not think that is the
correct way to interpret the bill text
Lay forward by House Bill 233 I would
also like to call attention to many
families who have babies who are born
with a life-threatening ailment can
choose perinatal hospice and I'd like to
lay forward the definition of what
perinal hospice is paranal hospice and
Pala of care is an Innovative and
compassionate model of support for
parents who choose to continue their
pregnancies following a prenatal
diagnosis indicating that their baby has
a life limiting condition and might die
before or shortly after B birth as
prenatal testing continues to advance
more families are finding themselves in
this heartbreaking situation perinatal
Hospice in incorporates the philosophy
and expertise of hospice and paliative
Care into the care of this new
population of patients this specialized
support is provided from the time of
diagnosis through the baby's birth and
death perinal Pala of care helps parents
Embrace whatever life their baby might
be able to have before and after birth
so in conclusion I support the passage
of House Bill 233 and I encourage you
all to support it as well thank you so
much for your time thank you for your
testimony are there any questions from
Miss Maloney
seeing thank you
again there is uh I see that there's
uh no other hands that appear to be up
at this
time and is there anybody else wishes to
testify who hasn't I see there's uh Leah
Cohen let's just put her hand
Cen
hi can you hear me yes we can hear you
uh good afternoon members of the
committee um again I was not uh planning
on I testified earlier this morning um
in opposition to several bills I again
was not planning on testifying today in
opposition to um House Bill 233 but
after listening to the hearings I feel I
must speak um I'll be brief because I
understand this hearing has been
incredibly emotional but I just want to
be clear this bill may not be directly
related to abortion it should be noted
that 66% of granite Staters support
abortion in all cases which is Five
Points higher than the national average
and beyond that I would hedge a bet that
the reason why abortion is uh has
overwhelming support here in the granite
state um is because Granite Staters
agree the government does not deserve a
place um between you and your uh
physician and your medical provider
there is no reason to legislate
something that is a non-issue there is
no infanticide happening it was raised
earlier that there was a CDC report um
highlighting instances of this I would
just like to note that that report has
been discredited by multiple um OBGYN
providers um so I just do not think that
should be considered when you uh take
your final vote on this um I urge you to
um rule that this bill is um inexpedient
to legislate um this is an incredibly
painful uh situation that parents have
to go through um when there are medical
problems with their child um and frankly
it is inappropriate for legislators to
have a role in that decision-making
process um and I think that uh all of
your constituents would agree on that so
I urge you to itl this bill it is just
inappropriate um and not right for New
Hampshire thank you for your time um I'm
happy to take questions thank you Miss
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony and I see no other hands up
that being the case I am going to end
the hearing on House Bill
233 and note that I didn't do a very
good job of uh judging the time it would
take on that bill today so we have
another hearing which is scheduled for 3
o'clock
today and we will and the the other
thing I will note is that
uh representative MCB best points well
taken and I should have been more
assertive I think in uh stepping in and
addressing the fact that there were uh
personal references made and we'll try
to do a better job of that in the future
and with that uh I think we'll be in
recess until 3
welcome
six
yeah
okay we're all
live
here
us
yeah
I'm
message
questions
back we're schedule to hear at
that is a bill creating a private cause
of action for discrimination based on
hairstyles relative to a person's
ethnicity there is one sponsor on the
bill as
it sent to the committee and that was
representative Mary Wells representative
walls would you like
to speak to the committee with regard to
your
Bill thank you Mr chairman I
would um can you hear me correctly we
can hear you fine thank you thank you so
much for your time um for the record my
name is representative Mary Beth walls I
uh represent the towns of bow and
Dunbarton and Marram District 23 uh Mr
chair chairman I'd also like to point
out that there were supposed to be a
couple of co-sponsors on this and there
were a couple of problems with
legislative services and one is being
reflected in the amendment and the other
one is the lack of co-sponsors um and
the co-sponsors are submitting testimony
to you but the bill really did have more
support than just me it's just that
legislative servic has had an oversight
which I will also address the rest of in
a moment um so let me just start uh this
bill is intended to protect people in
schools and in the workplace from
discrimination based natural hairstyles
you have before you an amendment because
of a misunderstanding in the drafting of
this bill the bill is drafted exempts
Corrections Officers from the
requirement of the bill I really have no
interest in how Corrections Officers
wear their hair what I intended to do
was exempt prisoners because having done
my research on this it came apparent to
me that the Department of Corrections
had a problem with this bill protecting
prisoners so the amendment before you
fixes it the amendment is co-sponsored
by representative Smith who did this as
a courtesy to me because it's my
understanding that Amendments have to be
sponsored by a member of the committee I
called her and she graciously agreed
that she would be on my Amendment so
there's no question as to the
committee's ability to accept the
amendment the amendment does not replace
the bill it fixes the oversight in the
bill with respect to the difference
between prisoners and Corrections
Officers the bill originated with a
coalition known as the crown coalition
Crown is an acronym which I always have
to look up and it's called creating a
respectful and open world for natural
hairstyles it's actually funded by Dove
soap and if you go on to the website
you'll see Dove soap all over it but it
includes more than 70 organizations
across the country advocating for
legislation like this this legislation
or legislation similar to it has been
already been enacted to law in seven
states California New York New Jersey
Virginia Colorado Washington and
Maryland and it's also been enacted in
several cities and currently in this
current session it's introduced in over
20 States as well and while the crown
Coalition focuses their work on the
workplace this bill is broader and it
also includes
schools there is a long history of
discrimination based on natural
hairstyles our perceptions of attractive
hairstyles are rooted in white Skinner
of appearance that perpetuate
stereotypes that natural hairstyles are
unprofessional this is an unconscious
bias by people who are not
black natural hairstyles are three times
more likely to be perceived as
unprofessional people with natural
hairstyles are rated less ready for a
job when asked 80% of black women report
having to change from a natural
hairstyle to fit into their office this
is no small thing changing for from
natural hair often involves regular
loose of expense use of expense of harsh
chemicals and excessive heat while the
men in the room may not be able to
relate to this I expect several women
will understand that this is like
coloring your hair but much
harsher uh this is not just a workplace
issue in schools there are plenty of
documented cases of children being given
detention suspended or expelled for
wearing natural hair there are cases of
children being refused admittance to
private schools there are documented
cases of athletes being told to cut
their hair or they're off the
team these are outdated views but they
persist even the military now allows
women to wear dreadlocks or locks as
they're now called and did anyone notice
the hairstyles on the field in the Super
Bowl on
Sunday there were certainly plenty of
natural hairstyles
there today you will hear stories both
from students and from fellow
Representatives about their
experiences often this type of bias goes
unrecognized yet discrimination based on
natural hairstyles has legal economic
and psychological costs a 2019 study
found that there is immeasurable impact
on black women black women are one and a
half times more likely to be sent home
from the workplace due to their hair
black women are 30% more likely to be
called in and told about office policies
with respect to hair and
hygiene hair discrimination is race
discrimination race is a protected class
but the one case to address this issue
or in the one case to address this issue
the 11th circuit refused to support the
findings of the EEOC that discrimination
due to natural hair is prohibited hence
legislation like this is necessary to
ensure Protections in a place like New
Hampshire if you are familiar with the
Discrimination laws in h New Hampshire
you may have noticed that this bill
creates a private right of action rather
than send victims to the New Hampshire
Civil Rights Commission victims would
still have the option of going through
the commission but I believe that a
faster remedy is necessary a student
told to cut his hair before he can join
a sports team cannot wait the one to six
months it takes for the commission to
act they need an opportunity for
immediate relief the sports season could
well have ended before the commission
could ask the same is true of job
applicants and other for unforeseen
victims this is why I am proposing a
Second Avenue of relief for victims of
this
discrimination some of you may think
that because the most egregious cases
documented in the Press are not based
here in New Hampshire that there's not a
problem here in New Hampshire that would
be
naive discrimination happens everywhere
and we need to make it clear that it's
not acceptable here in New
Hampshire I ask that you recognize that
discrimination based on natural
hairstyles has far-reaching consequences
in law
in the workplace in schools and is
followed by economic and psychological
consequences and I ask that you vote
this bill ought to pass and send it to
the Full House for passage and Mr
chairman I have a question for you I
sent you an email earlier today with a
list of witnesses that had failed to
make the timeliness to sign up to speak
and I don't know if you've seen that
email or not but if not I have the list
of witnesses I have it in front of me um
I just got a call as this hearing was
about to open from AO outh who said
she's stuck in traffic in Washington DC
in a car and asks that you call her
fifth on this list she said that her GPS
said she'd be home by 3:15 so I just
bring that to your attention otherwise
we're going to be talking to her in a
car
okay thank you thank you are there
questions for representative
walls yes representative Alexander um
thank you Mr chair and thank you
represent walls for taking my question
um I'm looking specifically the the the
um statute we're looking at is um RSA
193 um colon 38 and this applies
specifically to discrimination in public
schools um yet some of your um testimony
is talking about how this would apply to
private schools as well um I'm wondering
if you can clear that up um with me
because I'm curious about that and then
also if I can have another one from the
chair um do you have I I understand we
would buy be naive and not finding a
specific example in New Hampshire but do
you have specific examples from New
Hampshire where this has been a problem
um and why doesn't this qualify under
like the existing protected class of
race thank you for the question um I'm
going to take these in reverse order I
would argue it does qualify under the
protected class of race the 11th circuit
found differently the EEOC did find it a
protected class the 11th circuit refused
to uphold that and when the 11 circuit
refused to uphold it as when the crown
Coalition was created and people started
introducing these bills nationally in
both states and cities um in terms of
specific examples in New Hampshire I
don't have one that's hit the Press but
you're going to hear testimony from
students here in New Hampshire as well
as from fellow state representatives
about their experiences here I think
that at least all of them are at least
some of them are right here in New
Hampshire so we don't have things that
hit the newspaper like some of the high
PR profile cases that you'll find when
you go on the internet but it most
certainly is happening here um and your
first question was citing I'm sorry your
first question was I was talking
specifically about the the RSA that
we're talking about is public schools
and you cited a bunch of uh like an
example of private schools does this
apply to private schools as well it's my
understanding it does not I'm not sure
that we have the authority to regulate
that kind of thing at private school
unless they get Federal money if they
get Federal money absolutely it does but
if they don't get Federal money and I
think most private schools don't then I
don't don't think we have the authority
to do it but I I would not want to stake
my life on that perhaps one of the other
lawyers on the committee has a better
sense of that than I do thank
you thank you representative syvia do
you have a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question
um I'm trying to figure out in this
section 193 col 38 where you're trying
to define
race um
and you're using a rather circular logic
in my
opinion um race means immutable traits
associated with race
uh I I have a hard time following that
logic can you help me
um I think let me just pull this up real
quick I don't have the the bill in front
of me um give me one
second
um I think it's probably uh simply not
the best drafting you know I sent it
into legislative services and I agree
that's not great drafting to say race
um that's the best I can tell you uh you
know it's just not perfect drafting I
think if you've a court trying to
interpret it they would understand what
you're trying to say um I think race has
a a plain meaning in and of itself and
that's how it's used the second time in
that sentence um but I think you could
have taken out uh rate the second race
there and simply said race means traits
including and go on and Define it from
there if I can follow up yes you may so
as we continue in that line uh it it
uses including hair texture and
protective hair Styles and then it goes
to apparently defining protective
hairstyles
also
um yes drafting is a little bit of a
problem I would say but is this to say
that um race has only to do with hair
texture and hair
styles no it's not meant to be limiting
it's meant to be
expanding
thank
you are there any other questions for
the
sponsor seeing none thank you for your
testimony today thank you very much for
your
chair chairman gon and committee members
honorable committee members thank you
for my testimony I am representative
Charlotte D Lorenzo from New Market
representing myself in support of HB
359 by now you've probably learned that
the texture of our hair is mainly
determined by our DNA
for
African-Americans our hair has a
distinct curl pattern our hair texture
differs from the straigh or hair of
people of Caucasian and Asian descent
for instance people use many words to
describe ethnic hair texture for
African-Americans our hair has been
described as good hair bad hair kinky
hair curly hair nappy hair tight hair
coarse hair or worse hair styling Trends
evolv periodically from about the late
1800s African-American styling Trends
required chemical straightening or heat
applications such as curling irons and
hot Combs those treatments are very
painful and damaging to the hair
structure medical studies suggest that
chemical relaxers can cause
cancer in the 1960s and 1970s people
favored the natural look along Nam the
afro the bigger the afro the better the
look The Look went mainstream and people
of every ethnic background splited curly
perms during the 2000s African-Americans
began wearing natural hair styles that
Express their individuality and cultural
identity today's popular Styles involve
intricate braid patterns like dreadlocks
cornrows twist locks waves and curls
these styles are durable and longlasting
in 2019 a referee forced a high school
wrestler to cut off his dreadlocks
before he could compete in a match
following an investigation the New
Jersey attorney general suspended the
referee for two years and as a remedy
the school was required to undergo
implicit bias
training I support HB 359 a bill that
will help prevent such incidents in New
Hampshire and this bill imposes
penalties for
violations every person deserves to live
free without discrimination New
Hampshire's population is becoming
increasingly diverse as people move here
for the New Hampshire advantage in order
to maintain a robust economy and Supply
the job market with competent workers we
must offer opportunity to folks who are
looking for a great place to live work
and raise and educate a family let us
make New Hampshire more welcoming by
voting OTP on the HB
testimony thank you for Testimony
representative soov do you have a
question yeah thank you and uh thank you
representative D Lorenzo for taking my
question so how would this apply in the
case of a uh an executive counselor
shall we say uh interviewing or making
uh comments about a an applicant for a
Education well I'm not sure because I'm
not a lawyer but I think it could be
um a personal cause of action by the
person who feels they were discriminated
against or it could be go before the um
Attorney General's office or the
Attorney General's office of um
diversity
inclusion I'm sorry the human rights
committee thank you you're welcome
representa M Cen thank you Mr chair and
thank you very much for taking my
question I just wanted to follow up a
little bit on Representatives Sylvia's
observation about the expanse of nature
of the definition and so I'm just trying
to understand let's say someone who was
of Caucasian or Asian origin if they
were to adopt a hairstyle that was
African-American in origin does does
this cover them or is it just to cover
natural hairstyles for that race what's
the intent of it I guess well your first
question does it cover for instance
someone of a different
ethnic um Heritage than African
American yes I think it
would and what was your second question
I'm sorry representative so so so does
it cover a person that chooses to use a
hairstyle that is not of their ethnic
origin so um if if you were a white
person that really liked a hairstyle of
African-American origin does this
protect your ability to express that um
even though you're not of the same
ethnic background as that hairstyle
associated
with I really I'm really not sure maybe
um representative Waltz would be able to
answer that question or one of the
lawyers in the room thank
you thank you uh representative syvia do
did you have another question or did I
cut you
off uh no I uh I maybe my hand didn't go
down I'm not sure if I take care of that
or you do okay just just checking
representa sober yes thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question
would this bill as written cover uh the
hairstyles of hiic Jews who typically
have very long uh sideburns call pus and
would I mean part of the intent intent
of this bill is to protect people um
whose ethnicity um or
I would even believe religion
um favors a certain type of
hairstyle a followup Mr
chair but in reading the language here
and the additional language on lines 9
through 11 it seems to focus almost
exclusively on African-Americans and it
mentions braids locks tight curls Cur uh
coils or curls cornrows Etc uh nothing
about beards or U you know any kind of
hairstyle protected by or dictated by
religious
affiliation I'll to tell you honestly um
representative silur I think that a
that okay thank you you're
welcome representative
Alexander um thank you Mr chair and um
thank you representative for taking my
question um I'm concerned that the
language says it it says certain types
of hair it says including but it doesn't
have it's it doesn't add the not
limiting to so could you find that maybe
like somebody that does not have a
hairstyle um like or is bald um an
African-American would have grounds to
um have a cause of action because it
doesn't limit the exact
hairstyles
um with all due respect representative
Alexander I don't think that your
question question is dramatic to the
issue at hand or gerain to the issue at
hand
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony thank
you I note that we uh we have three more
people who pre-re pre-registered to
testify and another four that were given
in the list from that was previously
mentioned by representative Waltz so I I
need to just limit the testimony to no
more than three minutes to everyone in
this particular case we are supposed to
have conclude today by four o'clock as
because of some work that's going to be
done on the internet here at the
lob so um I'm going to call next on uh
available you could raise your hand if
there I don't
see
that person at least under that
there's hi um my name is Lydia Yen and I
am the lead organizer for change for
conquered in conquered New Hampshire I
am testifying today on behalf of myself
change for conquered and all students
and people of color who wear protective
styles including head wraps and have
curly hair change for conquered is a
group that works to eliminate racism in
our community and make it more welcoming
for young adults so naturally this is
something that we care about
deeply since this bill concerns students
of color as they are most affected by it
if it is denied we need to support
it students and adults should not have
to hide their natural hair or conform to
standards that are simply preferences
that and that don't address a threat or
inappropriate
behavior preventing them from being
themselves may cause unnecessary stress
which may also lead to a decrease in
school or work
performance this creates inequity in
schools and the
workplace the school system has had many
issues with racism and by approving this
bill you will contribute to the progress
it is making to bring about systemic
change in conquered focused on building
Equitable Ed educational experiences in
schools for all students in conquered I
urge you to demonstrate that you support
racial equity and inclusion by voting in
favor of this Bill thank you for your
time thank you are there any question
yes represented
Soviet thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question uh I see in a
list here head wraps and I'm an old guy
so I don't know what head wraps is and
for the sponsor I would note that it's
um written as one word in one place and
two words in another place can you tell
me what a hebra
is um from an African woman perspective
um this is a way for us to like we wrap
our head um in a scarf to protect our
hair from like w from the weather um
pretty much and from other natural like
things that could damage our hair
thank
you any other questions from Miss
Yan see none thank you Miss Jen for your
testimony
today thank you
and we have an individual by the name
of
a
asamoa is aahu asamoa I see on the
list I I think they asked she was
traveling is that the person I yeah I
think that was who representative walls
Assa hi um can you all hear me yes we
can awesome um hello my name is Stella
ASA um I'm a member of the pi Theta
chapter of Delta data story Incorporated
and a member of the New Hampshire Public
um and I'm testifying in support of HB
359 um so it would be really great if I
could just give you all some
background um about who I am and how I
grew up and why this bill means
something to me um so when I was growing
up I remember watching young actors and
performers on television and in film and
thinking I want to do that that is
really awesome and I was extremely
inspired um I remember watching movies
like The Sound of Music and thinking I
want to sing and dance and act and
perform on TV um and have that be my
career in high school I performed in
theater and on stage um and by the time
I got to college I thought theater is
going to be the thing that I do for the
rest of my life
um I became
employed at a theater in New Hampshire
called Northern Stage it's a regional
theater and on my first day of rehearsal
I came in with my natural hair and I was
extremely excited because I never
thought that I would be 18 years old
working in a regional theater at that
point in my life and the director said
to me why did you come with your hair
like
that and I said I'm confused I don't
understand um and he had explained that
because my natural ha so big that nobody
could see my face and that the scenes
didn't make as much sense and that
basically my
appearance was impeding the rehearsal
process I went home and I had a panic
attack I could not believe that me
coming into
rehearsal just being in my natural state
could
possibly impede a rehearsal process it
it really shocked me the next day when I
went into
rehearsal I had covered all my hair up
and I wore a hood some of my castmates
were asking me Stella why did you cover
up your hair it's so
beautiful and I was too embarrassed to
respond I didn't talk about it my
director never brought it up again but
that experience almost made me
never want to do the thing that I had
vowed to myself was my dream as a
child this was in the state of New
Hampshire I think a lot of people wonder
how black women and bpoc people in New
Hampshire can possibly undergo hair
discrimination
and what I have to say to that is
anytime there is a black woman in the
room anytime there is a bip person in
the room who has a hair texture that is
not not deemed straight and pretty and
to be very honest white hair
discrimination is taking
place I think that it would mean the
world to me and a lot of other young
black women and young black people and
brown people in New Hampshire for
something for a bill like this for
something as magnificent
and something that actually sees people
who look like like me for that to pass
in New
Hampshire that would really be
lifechanging I
think the goal of my testimony today is
to make it clear that race-based
discrimination is real it is
happening it is in the coffee shops that
we go into it is in the theaters that we
sit in to go and and watch theater when
that was happening it is in our schools
it is in our colle colleges it's
everywhere
um so it would be so magnificent if we
could all
really read what HB 359 is trying to do
and understand
that this bill could make such a huge
difference thank thank you for your
missa
yes representative MC Beth thank you
chairman uh Gordon and thank you um Miss
ASA for taking my question um what I'm
wondering is
um we have this section and it talks
about race and protection I'm wondering
is it just race or is it also like
religion I mean could there be
Caucasian dis you know Caucasian Muslims
that might be I really don't know and
I'm also wondering if it needs to be
expanded to race and ethnicity and maybe
those aren't fair questions for you but
I'm curious just you know you've
referred to yourself as by ocp or
whatever whatever that acronym was I'd
like you to explain that too but those
are kind of my questions are is this
legislation do are we getting enough of
what we need I guess is what asking
thank you thank you yes um yeah that
question definitely makes sense thank
you so much for asking um so I will
clarify by POC is a term that means
black indigenous people of color
[Music]
um I
think in terms of you asking whether
Caucasian Muslims should also have
protection under this bill I I I think
the point of the bill what it's getting
at is to protect people who are by POC
who have texturized hair and who use
protective styles so I think that the
point here is focusing on by PC people
who are struggling in the workplace and
in schools um to help them get statutory
protection
so I don't know if that thank you
clarifies for okay awesome
so chairman may I have a followup here
can
so I really apologize um but what what
what protective styles what does that
mean what's the protection needed for
thank
so I can just explain to you from my own
personal experience so I use protective
styles because in the winter time my
hair gets really dried out so often I'll
put my hair in braids or twists um I
know a lot of people who have dreadlocks
who um use that as a form of protective
style um and all of these Styles you
know you go into work and I have
experienced at least three or four
bosses who have said to me what's on
your head what is that you know like
why' you come in to work like this um so
in short protective styles are yes
that okay so thank you thank you for
your testimony today say something
sure I I just as a matter of personal
privilege I want to comment to the
committee because of pandemic and I
haven't been able to get my haircut in a
long time I've started braiding my hair
at night as I sleep because it gets so
long mad added I feel like my mom my
kief you know that whole Christmas Story
thing it really is true so I just wanted
to make that point because generally I I
didn't understand and I can relate to it
now because my experience has been
altered thank you would you believe so I
said a y soes mlan so just to follow up
on that and maybe you're the right
person to answer this question maybe not
but this goes back to my earlier
question because I'm just trying to
understand if two girls apply for a job
and they're good friends and one of them
is white and one of them is black but
you know because they're two good
friends they're both wearing band two
knots are is it the intention of this
bill that both girls would be equally
protected or just uh the girl who that's
uh you know the the hair that is a
protective hair for her so I'm just
trying to understand what is the scope
of the bill and maybe you're the right
um
well so this is a tough question
[Music]
um because the point of this bill again
just to hammer back to my last Point um
the point of this bill is to extend
statutory
protection to by po people who have
texturized hair and who are undergoing
race-based
discrimination um and so a black woman
and a white woman who both have band two
knots you see a black woman is going to
be received very differently with band
two knots than a white woman will be
albe it whether or not that white woman
was given permission or um I guess the
go-ahead to get those band knots but if
you all understand what I mean
um the fact the fact of the matter is is
that when you are a black or brown body
and you do have um texturized hair
that's where the Discrimination
Prejudice thank you okay thank you are
there any other
questionsa see none thank you for your
testimony today thank you so
much we had uh on the list for from uh
representative wst was a chawanda Allen
chawanda
available I don't see Shaquanda Allen
hello hello missen hi I'm Shaka
Allen can you guys hear me we can okay
hi I'm shapa Allen uh owner of roots
natural hair shop here in Manchester New
Hampshire um today I would like to test
have a testimonial for the bill to be
approved because I have clients that
come in to get their their hair done and
protective styles and they you know
there's certain things that me as a
cellist I would like to do for them but
then they tell me no I can't do that
because of work my boss wouldn't like
this I couldn't have this color or these
things and it discouraged them for being
themselves when it comes to getting
their protective styles a lot of them
don't want to get the braid and they
need the braids get you know protect
their hair during the winter time but
they can't because they're scared of
what Society or the work place to say
about their braids and I'm here I open
my shop specifically to help that you
know keep us clean keep our hair done up
so that when you do go to work you know
no one doesn't have to say hey well your
braid look kind of crazy right now or uh
it's sticking up this way and that way
or you just woke up with an afro this
morning we want to help maintain the
afro keep it done um and clean keep the
hair clean so that you know we don't get
looked at as oh your hair is just crazy
and it's not crazy it's just you woke up
like this um I also help Advocate house
buity too into play which states that
you know as a natural hair styles we
don't have to go to school because of
you know the chemicals and things like
that and and I did that just so that I
could help people that wear their hair
and protective styles and naturally done
you know they don't go to the Sala and
get their hair colored or permed and
things like that I open the so that we
can get braid the dreads can get
retouched up and look clean um dread
people do wash their hair often and
things like that so help break some of
the stereotypes that's out there about
people with natural hair
care so I'm I'm testifying for this bill
to be passed so that I can give the more
confidence and to the clients that are
wearing their hair naturally and um
braids and things so they can be feel
confident going to work or just walking
out and society and not worry that
someone's going to judge them for their
afro or their dreads or their AB thank
thank you for your testimony are there
are there
questions from Miss
Allen seeing none again thank you for
testifying today we appreciate that the
anango
yeah it's onyango o n y a n Go
there
yourself can you hear me now hello
now
hello okay we'll come back to
zo and is a joah asamoa available at
this
point hello yes I am here can you hear
me yes who are you my name is AA B Asama
anyone hear me we can hear you okay
there's someone else speaking at the
same time so I'm not sure I think maybe
I along with someone else may be uned at
the same time okay all right so
greetings and thank you so much for
having me uh distinguished members of
the committee my name is AA B asoa and
as the one who developed the legislative
strategy for the crown act movement on
behalf of the crown Coalition that was
co-founded by Dove and the National
Urban League and the color of change and
others I am here to testify in support
of the crown act I will also address
some of the questions that I heard and
attempt to add Clarity regarding the
intent there is a longstanding history
and problematic practice of racial
discrimination based on hair in the
United States there have been countless
cases where black people have been
discriminated against for wearing
natural here and or protective styles
including but not limited to braids
locks twist band two knots afro Etc this
prevalent form of discre discrimination
includes being fired passed over for
promotions and even having offers of
employment rescinded it impacts the
upward mobility of individuals and
families who have are impacted and it
has been the reason far too many
children have miss school and had
negative educational experiences as I
think about the work I've done over at
the local state and federal levels I
think about a dynamic student Faith
finity in Louisiana who was sent home
literally in tears because she wore
beautiful braids that were deemed a
violation of school rules I think about
DeAndre Arnold in Texas who was told he
could not participate in his high school
graduation ceremony with his friends due
to Locks a display of cultural Pride I
think about people all over who
collectively gasp witnessing Andrew
Johnson a student wrestler in New Jersey
before forced to make a decision he
should have never been tasked with
making and to choose between having his
locks cut and his identity attacked or
forfeiting a match he had earned the
right to participate in based on Talent
the psychological impact of being told
essentially that the way you were born
is not okay is something people should
not have to endure as a licensed
clinician an applied behavior analyst by
training I should also share the damage
to one's self-esteem can be
longstanding and perceptions of self
worth can be impacted all in ways that
again shouldn't exist the issue of
narrow beauty standards in America
continue to perpetuate
inequity unfair scrutiny Injustice and
discrimination in workplaces and schools
the crown coalition's work is focused on
the workplace as well as school schools
and places where public accommodations
are provided those are all against black
people and it warrants a legislative fix
the crown act as the Coalition defines
it simply amends the existing definition
of race which is an existing protected
class it amends that definition of race
to include traits historically
associated with it such as hair teex
and or protective
styles while some anti-discrimination
laws currently protect the choice to
wear an afro afros are not the only
natural presentation or style of black
hair the crown act ures protection
against discrimination based on
hairstyles by extending statutory
protection to hair texture and
protective styles for this reason I
support the crown act as I reference and
without exception to address some of the
issues that I heard presented before I
was able to
testify race is not defined we know that
there is no biological basis for race it
is a social construct yet racism is
undeniable regarding whether this bill
would cover as the crown Coalition
defines it white people an example of
how bill would protect white people is
not just you know if a black person and
a white person has the same hairstyle we
show up we determine who you know gets
the job not that for example the a a
witness who testified before me shared
having a
salon if I have a braiding
salon and a white person is working in
the braiding salon and the white person
is told you must conform by changing
your natural hair to wear locks or
twists or BTO knots Etc the crown act
would then protect you because you are
told that told that you must change your
natural presentation of your hair in
order to have the job regarding whether
or not this bill covers religion
religion is its own protected class the
crown Act is simply a amending the
existing definition of race in full
acknowledgement that it is a social
construct to include the traits that are
historically associated with it I am
looking at a screen with 11 people if I
ask you all to define race I would
probably have 11 different answers we
could probably agree on what toppings we
would like to go on a pizza before we
can agree on the definition of race
again there's no biological basis for it
it is something that is assumed so
because it is an existing protected
class we are simply saying amend that
definition of race to include the traits
that are historically associated with it
hairstyle by mere definition is
something that is mutable race however
is not I will I'm born and I'll die the
same race again we don't agree on what
it necessarily is is but it's something
that is assumed so what we are seeking
to do is ex to provide
explicitly protection for those who may
be on the receiving end of hair
discrimination which we are defining as
race based discrimination so we are
simply seeking to Outlaw hair
discrimination based on race which is an
existing protected class so so we're not
attempting to create a new protected
class we are not attempting to conflate
it with religion which is also a
protected class we are simply saying
whatever people think race is amend the
definition of it to include those traits
that are historically associated with it
such as hair texture and hair styles I
sharing protecting civil rights is not a
partisan issue we do not view this as a
partisan issue it should not be the
responsibility of any one particular
party or anybody of one particular race
to protect the civil rights of people as
it stands now hair is not covered under
the current classification of race and
we are seeking to do that and I'm happy
to answer any questions people may have
now thank you for your testimony are
there than you for having me yes
attorney McBeth representative mcth
excuse me thank you your honor I mean Mr
chairman um so thank you I really
appreciate you clarifying some of the
comments that questions that I had
before and um I'm also wondering because
hair okay and this might expose my bias
or privilege or whatever but hair
interest in hair seems something that is
particularly something that women are
more interested in perhaps than men I
mean at least understanding I'm just
wondering is this um uh is
discrimination based on um hair texture
and hairstyle is this something that
impacts one sex more than the one gender
more than the other yes it
disproportionately impacts black women
although not
exclusively I mentioned two three
students of of who two of them are are
male and so yes it disproportionately
impacts black women although not
exclusively it also impacts black men
and of course our
children thank you Mr chair thank you
thank you for the question and allowing
me to answer any other
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony today thank you so much I
encourage you all to support the Bill
thank you next person to testify will be
daniello
UA
there hello can you hear me you
can um hi good afternoon my name is
Daniela
omero um I'm a senior at Dartmouth
College and a resident of hover New
Hampshire um and I am a member of the pi
Theta chapter of Delta Sigma data sority
Incorporated
um so I have two things that I would
like to share with you all the first is
I did a professional development program
um my junior year of college and um it
was a great professional development
program it taught us about things
ranging from you know how to fix up our
resums to like our cover letters to
what should the interview look like and
um like networking basically getting us
ready for um uh Life After College and
internships and applying the jobs um and
it was very valuable and it was really
competitive too um this particular
program it was it was for black
women and um there came up a a point in
the the program where someone act we
were talking about um basically the
interview like obviously like what to
say in the interview how do you
introduce yourself like what questions
to ask things like that and then it was
we then we started to talk about like
what to wear to the interview and the a
matter of here was brought up and the
woman that was advising
us um she was a black woman and she um
she Bally advised us
to not wear afro to the
interview um just because she felt that
you
know you're the the likeliness of us
getting the interview that us wearing
can hinder our chances of actually
getting in the interview and getting
past that stage and she said that it's
once you actually once you get into like
a job and you're actually you've already
like kind of proven yourself that that's
when you can kind of Branch out and
that's when you can actually wear your
hair now I would say like half of us
were natural in the room including
myself and I raised my hand and I had a
follow-up question and my question was
why is it that the hair hair that grows
naturally out of my head why can't I why
do I have to go spend money to do my
hair for the interview or like why do I
have to straighten my hair which I
haven't straightened my hair in several
years since I first went natural in
middle school and I'm I'm 20 21 now um
so that was when I last time I
straightened my hair was probably like
when I was 12 or 13 I don't put heat on
my
hair and she basically advised us that
we have to like do that in order to even
try to get the
interview um and so even after I I
protested she was something that she
really stand stood by and she really
advised us just for our best interest um
to do that and then the second thing I
to share is um missero I don't want to
cut you off but we I don't know if you
heard at the beginning we tried to keep
the testimony to three minutes if you
could if so if you could sum up that
would be great okay I was just gonna say
that um my experience um in Hanover New
Hampshire is that I've been constantly
told um to not wear my natur that my
natural hair is unacceptable that it's
unruly even with protective styles like
when I I have a job often like I get a
lot of comments that make me feel
uncomfortable at my job in Handover
because of my braids um from Handover
residence um and so that's that I would
say those are my two experiences I feel
like this bill is extremely important
for for residents of New Hampshire so
that we are not filled we are not
um basically made to feel like the way
we are naturally is
inappropriate um I think it's unfair and
I think it's really important that um we
pass this Bill thank thank you for your
testimony are there there questions from
M
omero seeing none again thank you for
your
testimony and let's go back and see if
we can find zo on yango I think she was
can hi can you hear me you can okay so
my name is Zoe oneno I'm a Handover high
school student and I've lived in New
Hampshire for my entire life and I'm
here to testify and support the HB
359 um my experience with my hair has
been very different since we live in a
very uh prominently White Community I
I've always felt like I had to conform
to something that I'm not um so I as
representative De Lorenzo mentioned I
got a perm and I straightened my hair
hoping that maybe I'd fit in better
maybe I'd blend in better and hope that
maybe if I erase this aspect of myself
I'd be liked more I'd fit in classes
more and I wouldn't receive the stairs
that I got when I used to wear my braids
um as representative D Lorenzo has
explained these chemical perms actually
chemically damage hair straightening
hair um actually destroys the double
helix pattern of black hair and so heat
is not meant for black hair um perms are
not meant for black hair but they're
simply methods used to make us conform
to something that we simply are not and
so I feel like passing this act would
allow people to exist as who they are
and let them know that who they are
doesn't have to be changed as a means to
um conform to an identity that they
simply are not um thank you for my
testimony thank you for hearing my
questions not thank you very much for
your testimony today thank you uh that
in concludes the people that are
pre-registered or uh we knew about prior
to today's hearing but there are a
couple of people with hands up and call
kandel hello uh my name is Grace K uh
thank you to the committee for giving me
the opportunity to speak um like I said
my name is Grace K I am the program
coordinator with the American friend
service committee um I also grew up in
New Hampshire and have lived in
Manchester for the majority of my life
um I am here in support of HB 359 and
strongly urge the committee to pass this
bill
I am a black woman with kinky curly hair
and that I'm currently wearing in locks
and I have sported hair of all kinds
including braids twist weaves and I
currently own baskets full of hair wraps
I went to school um in Manchester I went
to school um in conquer at the high
school at Bishop Brady and I have a I
have keen and clear memories of the
number of times that I have had to I
have gotten detentions for being quote
unquote out of dress code um and I have
a long list of of stories of being going
out into the workforce and having to
field um a lot of inappropriate comments
as well as um questions about whether my
hair was appropriate even though it
looked very nice um and so I wanted to
to First Echo all of the things that the
incredible Witnesses before me have come
um to to speak of and to really urge the
committee to understand that New
Hampshire oftentimes in New Hampshire um
it is often thought that New Hampshire
doesn't have uh behaviors or doesn't
experience um instances of U racial
discrimination discrimination or
race-based um uh uh treatment and I
think it is really important as someone
who has lived in this state since she
was three years old has went to school
here has experienced it for it to be uh
well known that these things do happen
and a bill like this goes a long way to
communicating the the values that New
Hampshire says that we are which is a
community a family based Community one
that rallies for one another and shows
up for each other and I think that these
are one of the ways that our legislature
and our lawmakers can certainly and
signal and be made real clear that when
we say that we are an inclusive
community that we say we are an
inclusive State we have the the teeth um
to back that up thank you and I'm happy
to take any questions thank
you any uh any questions for is
Ki
K thank you very much thank you for your
testimony today thank you we have a
Joseph
laaz hello can everyone hear me can all
right thank you very much my name is
Joseph laskas I will be representing the
American civil liberties Union of New
Hampshire um I just wanted to note that
we do support the intent of this bill we
did have concerns with the exclusion of
residents at the Department of
Corrections um and I just wanted to
point after all the testimony that we've
heard today um individuals shouldn't be
discriminated against uh just because
they may have made a mistake in the
community that that landed them um
incarcerated so uh for that reason and
because of the fact that um we've been
having promising conversations with the
Department of Corrections on some of the
changes that they are making to
accompany um this hairstyle
uh we we wanted to note the concerns
over the exclusion of residents and I
did want to say that um uh when the
concerns were raised over the residents
at the Department of Corrections this
was a security concern that was talking
about specifically people um having gang
appearance within their hairstyles not
the natural hairstyles itself so I I did
want to highlight that that was a
difference and a blinket exclusion is
actually still discriminating against
people and it would be discriminating
specifically against people of color
thank you and I will I'm happy to answer
any questions you may have thank you are
Sky seeing none thank you for your your
succinct and thoughtful
Williams good afternoon can you hear me
we
can hi everyone thank you for for being
here and thanks for allowing me to speak
on this issue uh I'm here to testify in
support of passing this bill and I can
give you a couple examples of why um I
am a junior at Dartmouth College I am
also a black woman and I am also an army
veteran and
reservist I do want to point out that
that just last month the United States
Army for the first time in its history
included protected hairstyles and
defended black women's ability to wear
those hairstyles in
uniform this
year it was a big step towards inclusion
and it was a big step towards in in
increasing representation of protected
classes in our
military I would go further to say that
New Hampshire is a beautiful
place I think more people had if they
had the chance to come to New Hampshire
would agree with me and I think this is
a meaningful step towards signaling to
the rest of our country that New
Hampshire is a place where people can
come to be
themselves as a black woman I have been
forced to do all kinds of things to my
hair not just to be considered
professional in a workplace in a
corporate space or in a courthouse
I was not able to wear my hair in its
natural hairstyle while I was in the
United States Army uniform
either to be clear one identity isn't
privileged over the
other what we're in a time right now
where even the United States government
and Military are
recognizing that this is a necessary
step towards protecting people who have
not been granted protections
before
I cannot tell you what it's
like to be on a
deployment and have to shower more often
straighten my hair more often and find
time to comply with standards that are
relatively impossible when it is 115
degrees
outside but I did
it those situations don't change when
you have a black woman in New Hampshire
who who needs to treat her hair a
certain way because it's I think it got
down to like below four last
night these issues are causing
harm now people are complying with them
sometimes for high ideals like the
freedom we all want and fight for for
our country other times they're fighting
for ideals like Independence and
supporting their family through the
their pride in their work I don't think
it's fair to burden these
people with
racist attitudes towards their
hair that's all I have to say I'm happy
to answer any questions if you have them
thank you for your
testimony and are there any questions
from the
committee seeing none thank you very
today
and I do not see any other hands up
other than people who have spoken
already we have a marina
liot hi can you hear me you
can okay perfect it's Leo um Marina
Leo
okay perfect um so I'm from Lebanon New
Hampshire and I have lived in Lebanon
pretty much my whole life my mom's also
she's a city councelor in Lebanon um so
I've been pretty involved I guess with
Lebanon and the the community there and
I am also um biracial so I'm a black
woman and I've lived in New Hampshire my
whole life and I was very excited to um
I guess speak with all of you today and
just offer my um support on this bill I
think this I was incredibly happy to see
that this is kind of an issue that's
being discussed with all of you today um
especially I think now with Co and just
all the discussions that we've been
having both at the state and um the
national level I am really encouraged to
see that this is a discussion that's
being had um and hopefully a bill
that'll be passed because I think um
mean especially for me personally I've
done every every uh every every
thinkable thing to my hair to kind of
fit in at times um and I think now I
really I wear my hair natural especially
in any Dartmouth and in any work
environment and I think that this is
really um important both from a from a
legal protection uh perspective and also
just really important um to set a
precedent and to really show um to every
New Hampshire resident and also to the
to the country at large that New
Hampshire is really trying to build an
inclusive community um so yeah I'm
really um and I'm in my senior year at
Dartmouth um so thank you so much for
giving me the opportunity to speak with
all of you today and thank you for um
really taking the time to have this
important discussion I think that's
really um I think this is really setting
a great precedent thank you thank you
are there any
questions seeing none again thank you
for your testimony
today and I don't see anyone else who
has raised their
hand
uh and that being the case I'll close
the
hearing on Hospital
359 thank everyone for appearing
today the U with regard to the committee
we are you I did send out an email last
night as I indicated earlier we will
have hearings next week on Tuesday and
Friday hopefully you can make it on the
Friday
and uh we'll have a you know full
hearing days on both days I tried to end
them a little bit earlier so we could
get out of here on a reasonable time on
both
days the uh Republicans I might add are
would have received an email this
afternoon indicating that they will have
a caucus tomorrow on the
committee
and is there anything else other
business that we need to talk about or
today that being the case thank
everybody for your patience today and
week thank you Mr chair thank you Mr
chairman